Achso, wollen wir eigentlich anfangen?
Das wäre vielleicht mal ganz gut.
Hi Köln!
Hi Hendrik!
Das ist jetzt Folge 6 von Akronomisierbar.
Yay!
Willkommen zurück, liebe Zuhörer.
Ihr seid tolle Menschen.
Wir lieben euch.
Ja, wir haben Grüße bekommen.
Die Leute hören uns durch.
Also vor allem
unsere engen Freunde,
die wir treffen und die uns dann sagen,
dass sie uns jetzt durchgehört haben.
Ich finde es cool.
Ich habe jetzt schon auch von Leuten
Bescheid gekriegt, die ich nicht vorher
kannte, dass sie unseren Podcast hören.
Also viele Grüße natürlich auch an die Leute,
die ich kenne.
Leute, von denen ich gar nicht wusste, dass sie uns hören.
Hey Manu.
Hast du ja vorher gefragt, darf ich jemanden grüßen?
Ne, ein Kumpel hat mich in der Straßenbahn getroffen.
Ich stand gerade an der Haltestelle, der vor dem Mittag
Straßenrand vorbei, wir grüßen uns und er hat mir hinterher gesagt,
dass er in dem Moment unseren Podcast auf dem Ohr hatte.
Also wir haben jetzt bestimmt schon
eine zweistellige Hörer einzeigen.
Bestimmt schon über zehn.
Ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass wir so groß und bekannt werden.
Berühmt.
Ja, wir haben
heute Themen.
Machen wir es so.
Nein. Was? Wirklich?
Wir haben heute eigentlich keine Themen.
Ich ärgere mich immer.
Ich komme in irgendeiner Situation
fällt mir ein, ach, das wäre was für ein Podcast.
Merke ich mir.
Ja, genau.
Das war es dann.
Und müssen wir mal durchgehen.
Wie macht man das generell? Wie kann man sich
Dinge einprägen, die man gerade
unterwegs hat als Ideen, aufschreiben?
Ich habe eigentlich so ein Buch, was ich da
in Folge 0 mal vorgestellt habe. Das bündete ich
immer noch, aber da schreibe ich meine Podcast-Ideen nicht rein.
Aber ich meine, wenn du gerade irgendwo
langladest, fällig die Stadt, dann
zwickst du ja auch nicht erstmal deine Notizbuchen, um dir was aufzuschreiben.
Am Anfang hatte ich da
einfach mein Handy rausgeholt, bin in unseren
Slack-Akronomisierbar-Channel gegangen und habe da
die Themen reingepostet. Das habe ich dann aber
nicht mehr gerne gemacht,
weil plötzlich irgendwie zehn Leute in diesem
Slack-Channel waren und ich dachte,
dann spoilere ich ja die Podcast-Themen, wenn ich das
da reinposte. Und der Slack-Channel ist ja
immer noch ein Channel in einem
... Ja, aber da sind
alle unsere Zuhörer drin.
Dieser Channel
ist total für diejenigen, die da nicht drin sind.
Ihr verpasst überhaupt nichts. Wir müssen uns mal generell
irgendeine Kommunikationsmöglichkeit ausdenken.
Also momentan haben wir ja ein Piraten-Pad,
aber da hast du auch gerade drüber rumgejammert.
Also Etherpad ist tolle Software,
aber Etherpad ist halt,
das hier ist sicher das alte Etherpad noch,
das funktioniert ja generell ein bisschen spannend.
Das ist das, was auf Java basiert, oder?
Was nicht, Scala?
Also irgendwas JVM basiert ist auf jeden Fall,
aber ich bin mir nicht sicher,
in was das geschrieben war.
Das neue ist ja in Node geschrieben,
das neue Electron,
aber beide funktionieren halt nicht so geil.
Ja, aber Zeit, dass wir das mal wieder in der neuen
Programmier-Sprache machen. Das hilft ja nicht,
es neu zu implementieren,
aber es gibt keine guten
Pad möglich oder keine guten
kollaborativen Texteditoren.
Es gibt noch Google Docs, wow,
das funktioniert technisch sehr, sehr sauber,
aber ist halt, hey,
Google, Google.
Ja, da ist das Interface,
was identisch ist zu so einem Word.
Das ist halt beschissen. Ich hätte hier
einfach nur eine weiße Seite, wo ich tippen kann.
Ja, so eine Art Markdown-Editor mit...
Boah, da möchtest du manchmal vielleicht ein bisschen kritzeln können.
Ach, da gab es schon schöne Ansätze.
Microsofts OneNote, aber Kollaboration...
Wahrscheinlich kann man sogar Kollaboration.
Aber das finde ich geil an OneNote.
Ich versuche mich immer wieder an OneNote zu gewöhnen als Note-Taking-App,
weil du da halt wirklich eine weiße, endlos Canvas vor dir hast.
Du kannst überall hinklicken, da einfach losschreiben.
Du kannst dazwischen malen.
Der Support für den Stift oder diverse Inputs ist fantastisch.
Also die machen sich da echt Mühe,
dir eine möglichst freie Sache zu geben,
aber das eine, was ich da gerne noch mit hätte,
als Feature geht nicht.
Nämlich das, wofür ich Evernote immer nutze.
Ich lebe sehr paperless,
aber da haben wir ja schon mal drüber geredet
und ich kriege meine Dokumente in OneNote nicht rein,
weil OneNote konvertiert mir PDFs zu JPEGs pro Seite
und da kriege ich die PDF nie wieder raus.
Wie da kriegst du die PDF nie wieder raus?
Wenn ich einmal eine PDF, also ich scanne meine Post ein
und die hätte ich gerne im Nachhinein
auch durchsuchbar und ich würde gerne
manchmal an die Originaldateien wieder rankommen, also
die Original-PDF-Scans, um die zu verschicken
oder auszudrucken oder sonst was damit zu machen.
Wann ist das gerne da Character Recognition drauf?
Meine Scan-App, die ich nutze, die
wirft da OCR drauf und das funktioniert sogar richtig, richtig
gut. Das embettet der auch in die
PDF-Dateien, das heißt die PDFs sind dann durchsuchbar.
Das ist echt stark. Aber wenn der es in
Evernote schmeißt, dann macht der da Bilder draus?
Evernote nicht. Evernote klappt da wunderbar
und
ein JPEG und schmeißt die einfach untereinander.
Und dann ist es erstens nicht mehr durchsuchbar.
Und zweitens kannst du das Dokument nicht mehr
rauskriegen und wenn du das über OneNote
versuchst zu drucken, dann
versuchst du das irgendwie auf eine Seite zu legen, aber
halt nie so, dass die JPEG...
Es ist so richtig kaputt. Richtig, richtig kaputt.
Ich habe mir gestern mal wieder einen Tag genommen und
meine ganzen Briefe,
die ich so kriege,
haben mir sicherlich mal aufgemacht.
Das macht die gar nicht.
Bei den meisten sehe ich von außen, muss ich darauf reagieren?
Nee, wahrscheinlich nicht. Ach so, wie der GZ.
Und dann schmeiße ich das auf den Haufen.
Gestern habe ich das einfach mal alles aufgemacht, sortiert und weggeheftet.
Nee, ich habe schon so einen Briefkasten,
also so eine Briefbox, wo ich das alles reintue.
Aber tatsächlich, der Reinhard von Methodisch Inkorrekt
hat ja auch von so einer Kiste mal erzählt,
die das Zeug scannt und sofort schreddert oder sowas.
Das wäre eigentlich mal ganz cool.
Du kriegst Post.
Schön wäre es noch, wenn das gleich die Briefe aufmachen würde.
Da gibt es ein Startup, wenn du damit leben kannst, dass jemand anders deine Post liest,
dann nimmst du dir als deine Postadresse an und die scannen das alles,
oder vernichten es, beziehungsweise vernichten es nur, wenn du möchtest,
und schicken dir halt nur die Scans dazu.
Also von der Idee her finde ich das fantastisch, aber das würde ich niemals mit trauen.
Das war doch so eine Dienstleistung von dem E-Postbrief,
dass sie dir eine Post aufgemacht, gescannt haben,
dir als E-Postbrief geschickt haben und dann dir den Brief trotzdem irgendwie noch geschickt haben.
Das ist ein Feature.
Oder nee, anders.
die haben das,
du konntest eh etwas als Brief schicken,
die haben das dann ausgedruckt.
Das wäre witzig, wenn der Empfänger dann sowas hätte wie du,
die kriegen das Papier,
dann hast du was Digitales geschickt,
was zum Beispiel mal zu Papier gemacht wurde
und was du auch nie gesehen hast.
Finde ich witzig, die Scan-App für iWise,
die ich nutze, Scanbot, eine tolle App,
die haben jetzt ein ganz neues Feature drin,
dass du deine Scans auch direkt digital weiterfaxen kannst.
Und die verschicken das als Fax für dich.
Das kostet, glaube ich, einen Euro die Seite.
Aber ich weiß nicht, ich habe in meinem Leben, glaube ich,
einmal selbst einen Fax gebraucht.
Über den FSR hier habe ich ein paar Mal
Dinge gefaxen müssen, weil die Uni die Grillanträge
halt nur als Fax damals so angenommen hat.
Und wenn du jetzt deine Post scannst,
machst du das mit dem Handy?
Ich hatte mal einen Hardware-Scanner,
so ein Teil, das ist ein Mini-Einzugs-Ding,
vom Profil her,
so ungefähr so breit wie mein Laptop und so
tief wie die Hälfte beim Laptop.
Nicht sehr hoch.
Den konntest du aufklappen, deine Dokumente
reinschicken, ich habe vergessen, was für eine Firma da war,
spielt auch keine Rolle. Da gibt es so ein paar kleine
Der war recht cool, in dem Sinne,
dass der einfach sehr hochqualitative Scans angefertigt hat
und hat die direkt in Evernote reingedammt.
Aber du musstest halt, das fand ich eklig,
den per USB an den Laptop anschließen.
Und die App macht das halt noch einfacher
und die Scans sind genauso hochwertig.
Also man glaubt es nicht,
was für eine verdammt hochwertige Scan-Auflösung
durch eine Handy-Kamera
und ein bisschen an Bildoptimierung dabei rausfällt.
Was mich jetzt verstehen würde,
wie sorgt das dafür, dass das gerade wird?
die Kanten von dem Bild
und zerrt das dann gerade?
Er sieht, wo die Kanten von dem Papier sind. Du musst das halt
bestenfalls eine weiße Seite nicht auf dem weißen Tisch legen.
Und er hält die Kamera
drüber. Der weist sich noch darauf hin, bitte
highlighte direkt die Seite
auf dem Bild live. Das ist ziemlich cool.
Und eine andere App, Scannable, benutzt.
Die ist direkt von Evernote. Funktioniert beide gleich.
Um mal zwei Empfehlungen auszusprechen, wenn ich nur eine
scannen würde.
Du weißt, dass wir hier kein Geld für kriegen.
Ich weiß. Deswegen will ich ja nicht einseitig nur eine App
highlighten. Alle anderen Apps sind bestimmt
genauso gut. Nein, die beiden sind echt klasse.
Und du hältst es halt so drüber und
der sagt dir bitte halt mal, versuch gerade zu halten,
aber der kann auch ein bisschen eine Trapezkorrektur
machen und was auch immer die perspektivische
Verzerrung angeht. Und am Ende
optimiert er das Bild noch im Sinne von, dass es eine
weiße Seite hat, einen weißen Hintergrund hat. Und wenn Farbdinge
drauf sind, dann versuch das farbig zu halten, kannst du auch
noch einstellen. Aber so ein paar Sachen,
ein paar Features, die diese automatischen Scanner da nicht
abbilden, ist halt, wenn wirklich in einem Brief
was drin ist. Ich habe ja ein paar lustige
Sachen gefunden. Meinst du Glitzer?
oder was? Ja, nee.
Oh Gott. Damit hast du dann
direkt das Gerät kaputt gemacht wahrscheinlich.
Aber ich habe festgestellt, dass mir die Bahn
letztes Jahr zwei Bahncards geschickt hatte.
Ach so? Ich habe nochmal nachgeguckt,
dass ich nicht für zwei bezahle.
Aber ich dachte mir, warte mal,
ja, ach cool, eine Bahncard.
Ach, das ist die von diesem Jahr. Ja gut, dann laufe
ich ja schon eine Weile mit der Abgelaufenen rum.
Dann stecke ich die mal in mein Portemonnaie.
Wollte die alte raus, die Anfang 2017
abgelaufen ist. Dann mache ich noch ein paar Briefe auf.
Hä, das ist nochmal eine Bahncard?
Läuft bis 2017.
Das hatte ich jetzt echt eine Weile da rumliegen.
Ich habe es noch nicht vermisst, aber ich bin ja schon eine Ruhe gekommen.
Spannend.
In einem Umschlag waren irgendwie 5 Euro drin.
Okay.
War auch ganz gut.
Schiff mal seine Post dabei mal durch.
Es ist immer ganz gut, wenn du Geld findest und dann ist es wichtig, dass es die Währung noch gibt.
Ich habe mal irgendwo in einem alten Sack und einen 20-Mark-Schein gefunden.
Oder 500-Rupien-Scheine, die halt kein Legal Tender mehr sind seit einem Jahr oder so.
Wo hat man denn mit Rupien bezahlt?
Überhaupt nicht. Ich komme bloß gerade zu, dass
Geld abgeschafft werden kann.
Aber das war ja,
der Indien sich einfach dazu entschieden, das Geld abzuschaffen,
die großen Scheine, und die waren einfach
ein paar Tage später schon kein
Legal Tender mehr. Ach, Indien, genau.
Das hat zu Todesverhältnissen
geführt. Das war eigentlich eine ganz große Tragödie.
Ja, aber die Bevölkerung ist im Großen sehr glücklich
damit. Die Bevölkerung ist ja auch
groß.
Da gab es auch einen guten
Planet Money Podcast zu, vor kurzem, glaube ich.
Okay.
Das war, weil so viele Leute irgendwie Schwarzgeld gebunkert hatten.
Ja, du hast ja die in einer Riesen-Szene, was das angeht.
Die wenigsten Leute, die Geld haben, zahlen und steuern.
Also ich habe keine genaue Ahnung,
aber das ist, glaube ich, schon ein recht großes Problem.
Mal kommen wir zur Bahncard.
Ich habe letztens auch einen Brief bekommen von der Bahn,
weil meine Bahncard abgelaufen ist.
Und ich fand den Brief einfach so herrlich und so,
ihr seid Arschlöcher, liebe Bahn.
Da stand einfach nur drin als Brief.
ja, dort findet eine krasse Party statt,
aber du kannst leider nicht hin,
weil deine Bahncard abgelaufen ist.
Echt jetzt?
Also du hast sie gekündigt, oder?
Ich habe sie gekündigt und die ist dann ausgelaufen.
Dann kommt da sich so ein Brief so,
tut uns leid, dass du leider nicht zu dieser Party fahren kannst,
weil deine Bahncard ist ja abgelaufen.
Was soll das?
Habe ich dir erzählt, wie ich letztes Wochenende
nach Hause gefahren bin?
Nee.
Ich hatte meine Familie besucht
und wir haben den Geburtstag
gefeiert und
dann, das war Freitag
und
Samstag ist mein Vater da nochmal
los
und ruft dann an und sagt, wir haben
einen Todesfall.
Mein Auto ist gerade...
Das war wie sein Dienstwagen,
mit dem er schon,
der hat 370.000
Kilometer runtergehabt. Das war ganz gut.
Plötzlich stand er da,
glücklicherweise nur anderthalb Kilometer von einem,
Autohäuser da und dann gehen wir weg und
hat dann einen kompletten Motorstillstand.
Dementsprechend
musste ich mein Auto dort lassen und bin dann
mit der Bahn zurückgefahren. Da habe ich auch gedacht,
kann ich mal wieder Bahn fahren. Seitdem ich das Auto
habe, bin ich immer bloß mit dem Auto zu meinen Eltern gefahren,
weil es irgendwie
zeitflexibler
ist. Jedes Mal, wenn ich dann mit dem
Autofahrer denke, jetzt bin ich zwar eine Stunde
schneller da, aber das sind halt zwei
Stunden Autofahrt, die ich nichts machen kann, außer Autofahren.
Da fahre ich lieber
drei Stunden Zug und kann nebenbei
an mir und dann habe ich mich schon gefreut, dass ich endlich
mal wieder so eine schöne
Hack-Bahnfahrt machen kann.
Füße hoch wegen das Fenster gucken und dann dabei
irgendwie einen Code schreiben. Schön.
Habe ich mir hier
mit der Bahn-App mein Ticket
geklickt,
sitze im Zug, 22 Euro
kostet das, sitze im Zug,
werde kontrolliert, habe meine Bahncard
nicht dabei.
Und dann? Ja,
aber gucken Sie doch mal, hier steht mein Name drauf
und ich kann ja nur mit der Bahncard,
kann ich ja nur, und da steht drauf, dass ich das mit
Bahncard 50 gemacht habe, und das kann ja
nur ich, wenn ich eine gültige Bahncard besitze.
Und gucken Sie mal, ich kann mich ausweisen.
Wenn Sie mir Ihre Bahncard nicht zeigen können, dann
ist das gar nicht alleine.
Was passiert denn da?
Dann hast du halt kein gültiges Ticket,
dann berechnen Sie dir.
Dann hat er gesagt, gut, okay, dann
wo sind Sie eingestiegen?
Da und da? Dann hatte ich ja dummerweise
gezeigt, wo ich eingestiegen bin, sonst hätte ich vielleicht noch
zwei... Gerade eben.
Wir fahren doch gerade los.
Ja, genau. Ich habe ganz schnell die Schuhe ausgezogen.
Ja, dann habe ich die Strecke nochmal bezahlt.
Dann habe ich den Rest der Strecke.
Ab der nächsten Haltestelle habe ich dann versucht zu stornieren.
Also ich habe mein alter Sticket versucht zu stornieren.
Das geht natürlich auch nicht, weil du am Tag der Reise dann 15 Euro dafür zahlst.
Das heißt, ich habe 5 Euro effektiv zurückbekommen.
Und dann habe ich nochmal die gesamte Strecke zum Normalpreis gezählt.
Das heißt, ich habe faktisch nicht zum halben Preis dieses Ticket gekauft,
sondern zum anderthalbfachen Preis.
Also hat die Bahn in weiser Voraussicht
deines anstehenden Fehlers schon mal eine zweite
Bahncard zugeschickt, damit du daran denkst,
die einzustellen?
Das ist bloß, weil ich vor ein paar Wochen, weil ich das halt nicht mehr so häufig mache,
mit der Bahn fahren habe. Vor ein paar Wochen habe ich mal vor irgendeiner
Platte mein Portemonnaie ein bisschen dünner gemacht
und da habe ich die ausgepackt gehabt
und zu Hause lag die halt bei mir im Regal.
Wenn sie sich braucht, brauchen sie sich mit.
Jetzt habe ich sie wieder dabei.
Wer weiß, wenn ich das nächste Mal mit der Bahn fahre.
Das ist ärgerlich.
Sicher, sicher. Kannst du ja am nächsten DVB-Kontrolleur vor die Augen
niesen meine Bahncard.
schön. Das war
witzigerweise sind die Leute ja im
RE und RB halt nicht
so freundlich, wie sie dann im IC und ICE sind.
Im
ICE saß ich dann auf dem zweiten Teil
der Strecke und dann hat der Kontrolleur mir auch gesagt,
gucken Sie mal, wir sind im ICE, Sie haben hier
ein Ticket für IC, aber
wollen wir mal nicht so sein.
Und der andere
ist da eiskalt gewesen.
Da war ich dann auch so pappig, dass sie gesagt haben, ja gut, dann verkaufen
Sie mir halt ein Ticket, da haben Sie wenigstens was zu tun.
Ich war schon kurz davor, dem Trick
geben, dass er sich ein Eis holen kann.
Oh Mann.
Ich fahr selten IC. Ich habe keine Ahnung,
ob die da freundlicher sind oder nicht.
Wenn ich mit der Bahn fahr...
Eigentlich schon, aber die haben auch mit wesentlich mehr
Leuten zu tun und die haben auch mit
anderen Leuten zu tun.
Wenn du in dem RE oder RB
fährst, hast du halt die
ganzen Leute, die zur Arbeit fahren
jeden Tag und du hast viele Kinder
und du hast
betrunkene Leute
und hast mehr Stress, glaube ich,
wenn du in einem ICE oder einem IC unterwegs bist,
da hast du erstens mit mehr Leuten zu tun
und die sind da auch, glaube ich,
größtenteils ein bisschen pflegeleichter.
Deswegen sind die...
Weil die Internet haben.
Ja, das kann sein.
Ich will mir sagen,
dass ich mit einem Schaffner richtig gestritten hatte.
Ich bin nach Hause nach Ingolstadt gefahren
und die Fahrt in Sachsen,
dadurch, dass ich Student bin,
ist ja kostenlos,
wenn du mit dem RE unterwegs bist in ganz Sachsen
und habe mir deshalb nur ein Bayern-Ticket gekauft
und das reicht auch aus,
damals aber noch nicht.
Damals zählt dieses Semesterticket
für Studenten bis zur letzten
Haltestelle in Sachsen und das Bayern-Ticket
ab der ersten Haltestelle in Bayern.
Das heißt, du hast so ein bisschen so ein Stück Limbo.
Genau, das Stück zwischen Hof und Plauen
war halt, äh, andersrum zwischen Plauen und Hof
war halt nicht abgedeckt. Mittlerweile zählt
das Semesterticket, wenn du
nicht, wenn du weiterfährst
außerhalb von Sachsen, dann zählt es bis zur ersten Haltestelle
außerhalb von Sachsen, es sei denn, du willst
dorthin. Dann zählt es eben nicht so
Das ist total komisch.
Den poolischen Ausdruck möchte ich aber auch mal sehen.
Ja genau, also du kannst, wenn ich nach Ingolstadt jetzt fahre,
da komme ich mit dem Bayern-Ticket alleine hin.
Wenn du allerdings nach Hof möchtest, dann brauchst du für die Strecke Hof-Plauen noch ein Ticket.
Ja, aber wer will denn schon nach Hof?
Was ist das denn für eine Ausdruck?
Jedenfalls habe ich mich da mal tierisch mit einem Schaffner gestritten.
Der Herr kam halt genau gerade passend als Kontrolleur vorbei,
als wir zwischen Plauen und Hof waren.
Und ich habe aber nicht eingesehen, dass ich für die Strecke jetzt noch ein extra Ticket brauche,
11 Euro wollte der von mir haben.
Und dann haben wir uns halt bestimmt
eine halbe Stunde gestritten und zu dem Zeitpunkt
waren wir dann in Nürnberg und dann
habe ich halt gemeint, nee, ich
zahle das nicht. Das ist total
affigend für das Strecke. Man hat halt eingesehen, ist einfach gegangen
und dann bin ich ausgestiegen.
Du hättest auch aussteigen müssen?
In Nürnberg muss ich umsteigen.
Ich meine, er hatte aber schon eine andere Situation.
Einmal
habe ich es echt verpennt. Ich habe mir angewöhnt, ich muss ja auch
ab Sachsen ab der Grenze dann
mein Ticket lösen.
habe das dann immer so gemacht, dass ich irgendwie
ab der Hälfte der Strecke dann mit dem Telefon mal so ein
Ticket geklickt habe. Irgendwann habe ich es auch
mal vergessen. Einmal kam
die Kontrolleurin so am anderen Ende
des Abteils rein und ich so
hat schnell das Telefon rausgeholt
und schnell ein Ticket geklickt.
Und einmal hat er mich überrascht und stand direkt
neben mir und ich hatte kein Ticket und ich so, oh fuck,
das habe ich jetzt vergessen. Können Sie in drei Minuten nochmal wieder kommen,
dann habe ich ein gültiges Ticket.
Das sind wahrscheinlich alles so Ausnahmen, die die eigentlich nicht machen dürfen,
aber es hat dann funktioniert.
Ich hatte diese App von der Deutschen Bahn direkt,
dass du irgendwie mit Länderticket, also mit dem Bayern- oder Sachsen-Ticket,
deine Mitfahrer noch im Zug organisieren kannst und die dann im Zug findest.
Und du sagst dann, hey, ich ist in Abteil 3.
Hat man nicht mal über sowas nachgedacht, sowas selber zu bauen?
Ja, aber es gibt ja direkt was von der Deutschen Bahn dafür.
Das heißt, ich habe die Währung viel gesehen.
Ich sehe nur so viele Leute, die im Zug sitzen.
Hey, die haben ein Bayern-Ticket, sie haben es gerade alleine.
Wo sind die anderen vier Leute?
Ja, keine Ahnung, ich glaube, zwei Werken weiter.
Ja, dann geh mal zusammen, die blöde Leute suchen.
dann machen wir die zusammen los,
suchen die anderen Mitfahrer. Das ist mega witzig.
Die geilste Situation war eigentlich, dass ich,
das war ganz am Anfang, als
Handy-Tickets gerade so aufkamen,
dann habe ich dem Kontrolleur
mein Handy hingehalten mit dem QR-Code
und der so eiskalt,
da hatte ich noch nicht die Schulung zu.
Okay, was machen wir da jetzt?
Ja, wo sind sie eingestiegen? Ich so, was?
Ja, dann verkaufe ich ihnen
jetzt nochmal ein Ticket.
Hallo, ich habe ein kürtiges Ticket.
Ja, also
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie ich das abscannen soll.
Also mal ganz im Ernst.
Das ist ja nicht dein Problem.
Was soll denn das?
Da muss er halt an der Stelle kulant sein.
War er dann auch.
Aber die erste Reaktion so,
da habe ich noch nicht die Schulung für gehabt.
Wo sind sie denn eingestiegen?
Da kann der doch nicht davon ausgehen,
dass du dir jetzt ein neues Ticket kaufst.
Wollen wir mal zu unserer Themenliste übergehen,
die wir uns für heute mühsam geschrieben haben.
Ich habe hier aber auch ganz ehrlich,
was ist denn das hier eigentlich gewesen?
Achso, ja genau.
Convos, kennst du Convos?
Sagt mir nichts.
Was ist Convos?
Das muss ich nochmal raussuchen.
Hier war vor
ein, zwei Jahren, ist hier so ein Typ
rumgelaufen,
Australier,
Josh, cooler Typ,
hat irgendwie ganz viele Informatikstudenten
angequatscht, ob die nicht für den arbeiten wollen,
weil er so eine
Sprachlernplattform aufbauen möchte.
Und vor kurzem habe ich auf
Facebook eine Einladung bekommen, wo ich das nicht mehr testen möchte.
Das ganze Ding heißt Convos und da gibst du irgendwie
halt so eine Liste an Interessen von dir an
und dann kriegst du irgendwie so eine Seite dargestellt
mit Leuten, die ähnliche Interessen haben wie du
und dann kannst du mit denen halt anfangen zu chatten.
Zu conversieren.
Ja, ich glaube, der Hintergrund ist,
dass du irgendwie dabei deine Sprache trainierst
oder deine Sprache lernen kannst oder so.
Und dann habe ich mir gedacht, okay, das probiere ich mal aus.
Das Interface ist nur ein bisschen komisch,
weil das ist so ein Grid aus Chatfenstern,
die immer mal weggehen und wieder auftauchen
und sich nicht richtig rearrangen. Das war ein bisschen komisch.
Und dann habe ich
schon mal angefangen und auf der ersten Seite
habe ich direkt gesehen, Josh.
Wir haben ähnliche Interessen
angegeben, Softwareentwicklung
und
keine Ahnung.
Dann habe ich immer gesagt, hey,
bist du der Josh?
Schnell festgestellt, ja, das wir uns schon kennen.
Dann bin ich von einer anderen
angequatscht worden, eine Jacqueline aus Berlin.
Schön, das war ein schöner Reim.
Brasilianerin,
hi, was machst denn du so hier,
ja, ich probiere das gerade mal aus und
habe mit der fünf Minuten gequatscht
und irgendwann so, sag mal, hast du eigentlich was mit
dieser Plattform zu tun? Ich so zu ihr,
ja, ja, ich kann
ja, natürlich.
Bin ich euer einziges Mitglied, das nicht mehr
mit der Plattform zu tun hat?
Ich glaube auch, dass ich da irgendwie, also ich habe da noch ein bisschen rumgeguckt,
naja, okay,
die gehen alle so in diese Ecke, wie sie
aussehen, dass die
so an jungen dynamischen Startups
beteiligt sind, ist das wahrscheinlich alles Konvos
mit Gründer oder Mitarbeiter.
Das ist aber ganz witzig eigentlich.
Sehr an der Google-Stat-Page.
Die haben auch so ein witziges
Video gemacht, wo
sie halt darstellen wollen,
dass du Leute suchst, die mit dir gemeinsame
Interessen haben. Da ist ein so ein kleines
Sprachbabelchen, das möchte
Fußball spielen und es geht so rum und da sind andersfarbige
Sprachbabelchen und die möchten aber lieber lesen
oder Musik machen und
da kann er nicht mit denen spielen und irgendwann findet er ein ähnlich
aussehendes Sprachbabelchen, mit dem er dann Fußball
Warum muss das gleich ausschauen?
Was ist das denn für eine Message?
Ich habe mir auch gedacht, die Message ist ein bisschen blöd.
Warum kann dieser Bücherform
nicht mit dem Fußball spielen oder sowas?
Das ist ja schon wieder totale
Jogs versus Nerds.
Stereotype.
Aber ich bin mal gespannt, was hier noch draus wird.
Vielleicht chatte ich ja doch mal mit irgendwen und besser meinen englischen Bewerb.
Vielleicht mit einem unserer Hörer, wenn nicht.
Ich kann mal gucken, ob wir einen
akronomisierbaren Channel aufmachen können. Vielleicht kann ich ja als
Interesse hier mal akronomisierbar eingeben.
Achron, Ohio, genau.
Was?
Ich hatte ja gerade bei
Akro vorgeschlagen, die Stadt
Achron in Ohio, da war ich mal.
Entity Interest.
Ich kann dir, glaube ich, bloß Sachen angeben, die schon
in Noro-Ouftauchen. Also, ich interessiere
mich für Dresden.
Und dann
interessiere ich mich für
Programming...
oder 1 oder 0?
Das ist doch gleich geschrieben.
Und da gibt es...
Wahrscheinlich vielleicht filtern die da
die Spaces nicht weg.
Find people.
Please enter at least five more interests.
Oh Gott.
Gardening.
Podcasts
gibt es nicht.
Was hatte ich noch gemacht?
Jazz.
Ich brauche noch
zwei Sprachen.
German.
What is your German
Level? 1, 2, 3, 4,
5. Ich habe 5 ausgewählt.
So.
Was für
Interesse mich denn noch? Horseback
Riding.
Du hast ein wirklich sehr akkurates
Bild von dir, was du hier widerspiegelst oder ich
kenne dich überhaupt.
So.
Jetzt. Ja, dann
heißen hier alle
guest unter Strich und eine ganz lange Nummer
und mit dem kannst du dann chatten.
Oh, hier, aber dieser Guest müsste sofort
mit mir reden.
Weil das ich bin.
Echt jetzt?
Hi.
Like that?
Du warst die einzige Person, die mir vorgeschlagen wurde.
Ich auch.
Das ist ja eine sehr versprechende Plattform.
Sitzen nur direkt nebeneinander.
Ich glaube, wenn wir diese Folge
rausbringen,
sind da zehn Leute drin und sie interessieren sich
alle für Podcast.
Aber du hast einfach, ich habe nicht mehr Podcast genommen, ich habe aber
akronomisierbar genommen. Du hast akronomisierbar, nein, dann nehme ich das mal bei mir
raus, vielleicht tauchen dann fünf Leute mehr.
What is your level of akronomisierbar?
Ja, fünf.
Wir sind Level 5 akronomisierbar,
oder? Akronomisierbar Level 5,
okay. Ja, also ich glaube,
das wächst noch. Ich finde es ein bisschen
schade, dass die auch wieder ihr Logo
auf Basis von so einer Speech-Bible machen.
Diese Messenger sehen halt alle dadurch irgendwie gleich
aus, ne? Das ist so ein Kreis mit
so einem kleinen spitzen Eckchen unten dran.
Bei Dino fand ich das Logo ganz witzig.
Hast du das Logo von Dino im Kopf?
Diesem Gnome
Chabar Messenger?
Weiß es nicht mehr.
Die haben dann aus dem
aus der Speech Bubble, das ist gar nicht mal so
obvious, haben die einen Dino gemacht.
Oh, das Dino
Logo gab es noch gar nicht damals.
Das ist ja echt ein schickes Logo.
Aber das finde ich süß.
Das ist wie so ein richtig, richtig fetter,
kaum lauffähiger Dino.
Aber winzig.
If Animals Ate Fast Food.
Der ist einfach eine Kugel mitten im kleinen Schwanz.
Oh, der ist niedlich.
Gehen wir mal zu unseren GitHub-Stars der Woche über, oder?
Können wir machen.
Du fängst an.
Ich fange heute mal mit den GitHub-Stars der Woche an.
Ich habe mir ein witziges kleines Tool rausgesucht.
Das heißt How Many People Around.
Und das ist ein in Python geschriebenes Projekt,
dass die Anzahl an Leuten in deiner Umgebung versucht zu approximieren,
indem es über Wi-Fi versucht rauszusliffen,
wie viele Smartphones so in deiner Umgebung rumhocken.
Okay.
Und es gibt dir dann einen Schätzwert dafür,
wie viele Leute da um dich herum gerade sitzen.
Und ich finde auch den Disclaimer schön fett in der Remix.
It may be illegal to monitor networks for MAC addresses,
especially on networks that you do not own.
Please check your country's laws.
Service and Conditions
may apply.
Finde ich aber echt witzig.
Er zählt die Number of Pro-Requests,
die von... Achso, nee, stimmt,
ein Cellphone fragt ja so rum. Wenn du ein Handy hast,
dann fragst du die ganze Zeit in der Umgebung,
was da so für Netzwerke sind.
Und diese Pro-Requests zählt, der schickt nicht die
Requests an die Smartphones, sondern
der macht das passiv. Genau, der macht das passiv.
Und er snifft die mit.
Ja, nice.
Finde ich witzig.
Geht weiter in die Richtung von, ich erinnere mich immer wieder bei diesen Projekten an dieses witzige Setup von den Datenspuren, wo sie den Monitor aufgestellt hatten.
Und jedes Smartphone transmittet ja quasi zu jeder Zeit alle SSIDs, die es kennt, von denen es hofft, dass ein Netzwerk in der Nähe ist.
Du musst ja die SSID tatsächlich auch rausschieben, falls das Netzwerk versteckt ist, damit du das hiermit verbinden kannst.
Und das kannst du halt dann
dementsprechend drauf hören, was die Smartphones so für
SSDs in die Luft blasen.
Du musst als Gerät die ganze Zeit?
Wenn dein Handy sich mit einem versteckten Netzwerk verbinden möchte.
Ach so.
Aber nur wenn es das schon mal gemacht hat.
Oder wie?
Dein Handy weiß ja nicht sicher, ob das Netzwerk,
mit dem es sich verbinden möchte, sichtbar ist oder nicht.
Du musst ja nur gucken, was man gerade sieht, oder?
Ja, aber das kann ja sein, dass du dich mit einem Netz
verbinden möchtest, was du gerade nicht siehst.
Du kannst ja dein
WiFi-Netz auch so verstecken,
indem du es nicht public machst.
Also alle, die ich gerade nicht sehe, könnten potenziell
versteckt sein, deswegen wusste ich immer alle Namen
aller Bekannten.
Genau, um zu prüfen, ob die
gerade zufällig in Reichweite sind.
Und das machen Smartphones halt.
Deswegen kannst du halt, da gab es dieses schöne Setup
auf den Datensprungen, wo dieser Monitor da stand,
und einfach so die SSIWs angezeigt hat
von den ganzen Leuten.
Das ist ja so der Edu-Roam dazwischen oder Heim
oder keine Ahnung, wie die ganzen Leute ihre
Home- und Arbeitsnetze halt eben nennen.
Das ist immer witzig. Und da gehen die Leute vorbei.
Woher wisst ihr, dass das da steht?
Ja, dein Handy hat es gerade, dein Laptop da erzählt.
Stimmt, stimmt.
Ein cooles Projekt.
Das ist da meins aufgetaucht. Also immer schön
brav euer WiFi ausmachen, wenn du das Haus
verlassen.
Ich meine, das ist einfach...
Ich weiß nicht, was man da sinnvoll macht an der Stelle.
Das Feature an sich ist...
Also ich mache meinen WiFi nicht aus, wenn ich rausgehe.
Ich mache meinen WiFi nicht nur an, wenn ich in der Nähe von einem
WiFi-Netz bin. Aber es spart halt eine ganze Menge Strom.
Tut es das?
Ja, es bringt schon was.
Muss mein Handy nicht vielleicht ganz viel Auxiliary-Kram machen,
wenn WiFi aus ist, um das irgendwie
damit klar zu kommen?
Nee, eigentlich nicht.
Ich finde es ja immer gruselig, dass du,
es gibt ja,
das Problem bei WiFi ist es ja auch,
dass sich so ein Router dir gegenüber nicht
zertifizieren muss.
Jeder könnte sich einfach
überhaupt nie nennen.
Und du hast halt so Setups wie, du hast überall Telefonzellen rumstehen, die die Telekom betreibt,
die jetzt mittlerweile nicht mehr gelb und zu sind, sondern einfach bloß solche Glas-
Mit Magenta-Kuppeln.
Kuppeln sind, in der Gegend rumstehen, die die Telekom-Hotspots ausstrahlen.
Und wenn du da hingehst, siehst du ein WLAN, das heißt T-Online oder T-Mobile oder irgendetwas.
Und dann kannst du dich dann mit deinen T-Online-Zugangsdaten verbinden.
mit denen du auch deinen Internetvertrag verwaltest
und deine E-Mail-Adresse, wenn du die bei der Telekom benutzt,
und du machst halt eine Anfrage, wenn du das gespeichert hast,
mach da halt ein Handy jedes Mal, wenn es diesen Hotspot wieder sieht,
schickst du da erstmal seine Credentials hin.
Schick das, also es läuft wahrscheinlich hoffentlich ein bisschen sinnvoller,
als ich die Authentication mit dem Netz läuft direkt darüber,
weil dann hätte ich ja wirklich absolut keine Security, was das angeht,
dann dürften Telekom-Kunden ja generell gepornt werden.
Theoretisch müsstest du...
Ich vermute mal, das sind offene Netze und beim Versuch,
die sind ja alle so die Captive-Portals,
die dann eine Webseite vorschalten von der Telekom.
So wird es wahrscheinlich auch sein, aber
wenn du das falsch einrichtest...
Ich meine, mich hält auch nichts davon ab,
hier einfach mich in die Uni zu setzen und ein Netzwerk namens
Eduroam aufzumachen und einfach mal
verbinden. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie die
Authentication beim Netzwerk abläuft.
Normalerweise hier beim Eduroam gibt es ja dieses
Zertifikat, was du dir in Zertifikat hinstellen solltest,
was dafür da ist, dass du weißt, dass es ein echtes
mit dem oder so.
Ja, ich weiß aber, ja,
schon, klar. Ich würde gerne
jemanden haben, der mir ein bisschen mehr dazu
erzählt, wie Authentication bei einem
Router spezifisch
jetzt abläuft. Was passiert, wenn
ich den Router für einen Verbindungsrequest
checke, was da genau Schritt für Schritt
passiert. Mich würde echt mal interessieren, wie
Passwörter übermittelt werden. Das ist wahrscheinlich unterschiedlich
je nach...
Das Abuse-Potenzial muss doch auf jeden Fall irgendwo
da sein, oder?
Ja.
Ich finde es immer cool,
auf dem Kongress, das Haupt, das
WiFi, was da ausgestrahlt wird, oder auch hier
beim Chaos-Nobüter-Club,
ich weiß nicht, wie es hier war,
aber beim Kongress ist es ja meist immer so, dass du ein
verschlüsseltes Netz hast und alle Leute fragen mir an,
ist das Passwort oder ist das Passwort? Ja, trag einfach ein, was du willst.
Es soll einfach ein Passwort haben, damit deine
Verbindung mit dem Netz verschlüsselt ist.
Es gibt irgendwie kein
Setup für ein verschlüsseltes
WiFi, was ohne Passwort ist.
Entweder ist es komplett offen,
das ist auch komisch. Aber ich glaube,
die Standards ziehen da gerade nach
im Zuge der
Snowden-Affäre ein bisschen nach.
Da gab es, glaube ich, schon ein paar
Vorschläge,
das besser zu machen. Der Kongress
hat ja jetzt eine festgelegte Location.
Ja, ich freue mich drauf. Leipzig haben wir.
Leipzig, auf jeden Fall. Ich habe mir überlegt,
dieses Jahr mal zu skippen, weil es schon wieder
so ein komisches
Jahr ist, wo du kaum
Feiertage hast, weil die Feiertage
auf Wochenendstage fallen.
Das ist alles ein bisschen ungünstig.
Aber wenn das in Leipzig ist,
dann muss ich mich ja nicht mehr um
Accommodations kümmern.
Dann kann ich da einfach
abends hinfahren und morgens wiederkommen.
Oder morgens hinfahren und abends oder gar nicht wiederkommen.
Mit dem Auto los ist es wahrscheinlich.
Mit dem Zug nicht wirklich, weil der fährt ja nicht mehr
zu, in Anführungszeichen,
humanen Kongressbesucherzeiten nach Hause.
Das wäre witzig.
Das wäre cool.
Das wäre eine extra Kurzzeitstrecke.
Das wäre witzig.
Die Haltestelle ist ja auch direkt an der Messe.
Ich bin mal gespannt, wie sie das machen,
weil das sind ja Messehallen
und die haben, soweit ich weiß,
hat die Messe keine Auditorien oder sowas.
Du kannst da, also Vortragssäle,
da ein bisschen blöd, das müssten sie dann.
Zum Kongress gehört halt.
Ein bisschen Pech alles selber bauen.
Nehmen Sie große Halle für die Lounge halt noch ein bisschen mehr dazu.
Die Lounge wäre in diesem Zwischengang
ziemlich geil. Das kann ich mir vorstellen.
Ich war noch nie in der Messe Leipzig, keine Ahnung.
Das ist eine der
größten Glaskuppeln in Europa.
Zwischengebäude ist ziemlich cool.
Dann gehen links und rechts
vier oder sechs
große Hallen ab,
die teilweise die ganzen Messebetreiber auch
gar nicht vollständig nutzen.
Ich glaube auch, die haben die Messe
hauptsächlich genommen, weil es das nächstgrößere
war, nachdem Hamburg nicht mehr
zur Verfügung stand.
Für eine Convention ist es
eigentlich nicht so gut geeignet.
Das, was der Kongress eigentlich war,
war Hamburg die größte Location
in Deutschland. Jetzt muss man halt
auf Hallen umschwenken, die man halt sich erst ein bisschen
zurecht machen muss.
Es war in der Messe auch schon auf Konzerten.
Das war dann in der Halle, da haben sie dann
irgendwie Sitze gebastelt, aber sowas wie so
einen großen Saal 1
in Hamburg können sie
dann nicht mal eben selber bauen, glaube ich.
Wo kriegst du die
Stuhlung dafür, dass die auch halbwegs
bequem ist und überhaupt
vorhanden? Oder es bringt sich halt jeder
einen Matekasten.
Ich habe auch vor, also da sein werde ich
auf jeden Fall dieses Jahr. Ich hoffe auch mal ein bisschen
früher, um mit dem Outbound zu helfen, aber das kann
ich noch schlecht einschätzen. Das ist immer bei
Weihnachten ein bisschen schwer, aber ich hoffe, dass ich
irgendwie am 25. dann schon mal...
Aber es ist schon mal was wert, dass wir von hier aus nicht
fünf Stunden hinfahren. Ja, und vor allem als Student kostenlos
hinfahren. Das ist noch das
Nächste. Super geil.
Das ist echt stark. Ich freue mich schon drauf.
Ja, Leipzig ist eine coole Location dafür.
Ansonsten können wir das Kongresszentrum
in Dresden, das ist ja
nicht mal ansatzweise ein Viertel der
Teilnehmer. Ich war kurz davor, das zum Spaß
vorzuschlagen, aber ich war nur noch nie drin. Das wird
wahrscheinlich längst nicht reichen. Nee,
kein Fall.
Wie hast du denn du für Getapsars ausgesucht?
Ich hatte hier so einen schönen Incident
beobachtet. Und zwar
gibt es ein Crate
in der Rust-Welt, das heißt
0 N-U-L.
Ich erinnere mich, ja.
Das war so ein bisschen
Rust's
Left-Pad-Incident.
aber nur ganz kurz, weil es es tatsächlich innerhalb
von einer Stunde gefixt hat.
Das war zwei, drei Stunden, aber egal.
Es gab zumindest so einen schönen Tweet von jemandem,
hat da zufällig jemand gerade
Cargo kaputt gemacht für alle Windows-Benutzer,
indem er ein Crade veröffentlicht hat,
was den Namen eines
reservierten Keywords
in Windows hat. Also du konntest
das irgendwie runterziehen und dann
oder den Index runterziehen.
Das ist gestorben beim Index runterziehen, ja.
Es lohnt sich definitiv, sich mal diesen, ich werde das in die Show Notes tun,
das GitHub-Ischi dazu mal durchzulesen.
Es gibt eine Liste von
reservierten Wörtern.
Wo habe ich denn jetzt den Tab?
Unter anderem halt NUL
oder auch AUX.
NUL, das sind halt Sachen, die du eigentlich
nicht, dementsprechend dann nicht als
Create verwenden darfst. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie das andere machen.
Wenn du halt ein
zentralisiertes System machst, dann musst du das irgendwo unterbinden.
Genau. Also so Sachen
wie CON, PRN, AUX,
0, COM1, COM2, COM3, COM4,
bis COM 9, LBT 1,
bis 9, das hat weiter und sofort.
Aber die sind relativ locker
und unpanisch damit
umgegangen. Das Crate gibt es auch
immer noch, es wurde also nicht gelöscht.
Die haben die beantworten, das ist unbedannt?
Ne, die haben aber einfach die Behandlung davon, glaube ich,
intern geändert. Es darf halt keine
Pfade geben, wo das direkt vorkommt.
Aber da musst du ja Cargo
umbauen, wie das mit Odolat und Crates
umgeht, oder?
Das wäre stark, wenn ich so einen Fick so schnell
haben. Aber ich dachte eigentlich, dann ist
geblacklistet den Namen und haben es unbenannt
oder so. Oder ich weiß nicht, was sie mit dem Projekt gemacht haben.
Was gibt es denn noch so für Package, die natürlich auch auf
Windows laufen, wo man mal so was versuchen
könnte reinzupushen? Na, alle anderen.
Jahn und NPM?
Ja, also NPM und Jahn benutzen ja
dasselbe Backend. Gibt es bei
NPM ein Package, das 0 heißt?
Und wenn nein, dann gleich.
Wenn nein, dann warum noch nicht?
Oder seit wann nicht mehr?
Sadly,
Package has no readme. Aber es gibt eins,
das 0 heißt. Gibt es schon.
Das wäre so ein 0.0. Was ist das hochgeladen?
Two weeks ago. Ja, das wird auch wahrscheinlich
jemand, oh, dann mal schauen,
ob ich NPM kaputt machen kann.
Ich würde mir das jetzt hier nicht runterziehen.
Stark.
Viele andere moderne Sprachen setzen ja auf
Dezentralität, was das angeht.
Und da hast du das Problem halt
nicht direkt, sondern wenn du halt
eine dependency Namensnuch reinziehen würdest,
aber dann musst du damit halt leben.
Was heißt die Dezentralität?
Wenn ich zum Beispiel
das wie Go oder Swift mache
und ich habe jetzt in einem GitHub-Report was...
Swift hat ja
einen Package-Manager, wie machen die das?
Dezentral. Du gibst direkt
eine Git-URL ein.
Und das ist alles, was
SPM, also der Swift-Package-Manager von dir haben möchte.
Es hat natürlich
jetzt danach...
Ist das gut oder ist das nicht gut?
Ich mag zentrale Package-Sources,
einfach nur was Discoverability angeht.
andererseits ist natürlich
gibt dir das viel mehr Freiheiten
und Namespacing
theoretisch mit
dann hast du so Fälle wie
dieses dvbpy
repo von dir, was geforkt wurde
von python3packages
die haben das swift repo
geforkt oder so
theoretisch existiert das ja an mehreren Stellen
das ist der selbe Source, du kannst von verschiedenen Stellen reinziehen
ich weiß auch nicht, was du
wenn du drei Packages hast, die darauf dependen
aus von verschiedenen Sources nehmen
Das ist halt immer ein grundlegendes Problem,
was ich sagen kann.
Deswegen
kannst du das nicht so einfach machen.
Dependency Management
ist hard, very hard.
Ich will auch nicht mehr sowas schreiben müssen.
Naja,
jetzt habe ich es da, was gibt es noch so?
Ich habe noch eins rausgesucht, das Projekt heißt
Electrino. Das habe ich auch gesehen, ja.
Da hat einer versucht,
eine systemeigene
Electron Runtime für macOS
zumindest zu schreiben, indem der auf Apple APIs
aufbaut und da einfach
die Electron-APIs
versucht zu mirrern, hat zumindest
für ein winzig kleines Substitur erstmal angefangen
und die halt darauf auch
quasi kein Chromium brauchst, um eine Electron-App
am Laufen zu halten, sondern das System,
was wir halt auch mal besprochen hatten, dass eine
System-Package-Chromium da schon helfen würde.
Genau das war, was ich
beim letzten Mal beschrieben habe.
Das hilft ja nicht, was Performance angeht, das hilft ja nur, was
App-Size angeht.
Und Aktualität. Ein großes Problem ist
auch, dass Chrome auf dem
elektronbasiert halt zu unterschiedlichen
Zeiten aktualisiert wird und vielleicht
zu langsam. Stimmt.
Du hast ja jetzt nicht nur
den einen Browser oder die drei, die du benutzt
auf deinem System ständig
aktuell zu halten, weil ein Browser ein großes
Attack-Surface hat, sondern für jede
Elektron-Anwendung. Das ist dick.
Für jedes Slack, für jedes Atom,
für jedes Code. Ich habe hier
mal irgendwo eine Liste gefunden mit
Elektron-Apps und die haben
halt potenziell alle veraltete
unterschiedlich veraltete Version von
Elektron als Basis.
Und das ist ziemlich geil.
Ich muss einen vergleichen, der wird mir noch ganz schön.
Hey, ich habe mal eine ganz billige Hello World App
gepackagt. Mit Elektron ist die
115 MB Großvallheit Korn.
Mit Elektrino ist die 170 KB
Korn. Ich habe mich letzte Woche
damit rumgeschlagen, mal eine Elektron
App auf Arbeit zu packagen.
Und das System,
was dahinter läuft, ist halt
super, super eklig. Zum einen hast du
Probleme, dass du es baust.
dass es 10 Minuten dauert und dann findet er beim
nach dem Bauen gewisse
Dependencies nicht nochmal, die vorher, wenn du es einfach
ausgeführt hast, funktioniert haben.
Und dann passieren ja so Sachen, wenn du
deine Dependency-Auflösung, wenn du
ganz viele eigene Sachen verwendest, die
potenziell aufeinander verlinken
und du deine Dependency-Auflösung nicht
sauber machst, dann hast du halt
hinterher ein Package, was da rausfällt, was
2,3 Gigabyte groß ist.
Geil.
Stark.
Deine Anwendung vorher ist, keine Ahnung,
hast ja auch schon riesige
NPM-Node-Modul-Verzeichnisse
in deinem Projekt drin liegen,
teilweise Sachen mehrfach, aber das ist dann
plötzlich, und dann ist es schon
irgendwie 500 Megabit groß in der Package,
dann wird es mehrere Gigabyte groß aus
Gründen.
Oh Mann, das ist hart.
Apropos Electron,
hast du mitbekommen, dass GitHub
jetzt ihren Desktop-Client neu
rausgebracht hat, jetzt als Beta vor
ich glaube wenigen Tagen. Was hat denn das mit
Atom zu tun. Nicht mit Atom
spezifisch, mit Electron hat das was zu tun.
Aber die hatten irgendwie gepostet,
GitHub ist jetzt in Atom.
Aha, vielleicht hat Atom jetzt auch
mit GitHub-Features integriert.
Da war ja, glaube ich, auch mal langfristig
was geplant. Aber
der GitHub Desktop-Client ist ja historisch
gesehen, also der ist jetzt nicht uralt,
bloß in, ich glaube, wenige Jahre,
wenn überhaupt, gibt es als
native Mac- und Windows-App.
Aber halt natürlich
völlig eigenständige Codebase, weil
Die eine sind C-Sharp geschrieben, die andere waren Objective-C geschrieben.
Was ja eigentlich schön ist.
Ja, aber sie kamen damit nicht mehr so gut klar
und haben jetzt ihren Desktop-Client komplett neu gebastelt,
und zwar via Electron,
und haben ihre vier nativen Entwickler, die sie hatten,
drei Windows-Leute und einen Mac-Typen,
darauf angesetzt, dass auf einer gemeinsamen Basis
in TypeScript und Electron...
Ich dachte, du sagst, das haben sie rausgeworfen.
Nee.
Und die haben das alle zusammenentwickelt
und fanden jetzt auf der Schiene weiter.
Also hier steht Introducing GitHub for Atom.
Das ist was anderes.
Das ist GitHub-Features in Atom drin.
Weil der neue GitHub-Client, ich meine,
die haben vier Leute, die daran arbeiten.
Und diese vier Leute mussten zwei Call-Bases maintainen
und hatten natürlich auch den Plan,
eine Linux-Version irgendwann anzubieten.
Und das wäre noch eine dritte Call-Base gewesen.
Die haben verschiedene Möglichkeiten evaluiert,
wie sie das zusammengeschoben kriegen.
Unter anderem, der gemeinsame Code liegt in C++ da
und die wrappen das dann einfach nur in UI.
Wäre wahrscheinlich sogar der sauberste Ansatz gewesen.
Aber jetzt haben sie halt eine Electron-App gepublished,
auf die sie mega stolz sind.
Aber ich finde die Kommentare alle auf Hacker News extrem zutreffend.
Im Sinne von, ihr habt euer Development jetzt gestreamlined.
Ihr seid mega stolz drauf,
dass ihr da jetzt mit vier Leuten gut arbeiten könnt.
Und die müssen jetzt diese Elektron-Anwendungen ertragen.
Und die Nutzer müssen jetzt die Kosten davon tragen.
Die Kosten trägt nicht mehr der Entwickler,
sondern der Nutzer an der Stelle.
Ja, toll, wunderbar.
Aber stimmt, hier gibt es nochmal eine Extraseite.
Das Produkt sieht fast genauso aus.
Es gibt GitHub für Atom.
Ach, diese Webseite, die zählt ja eh nicht.
Das ist schlimm.
Und dann gibt es hier
desktop.com
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ich habe noch nie das Bedürfnis
gehabt, für GitHub eine Desktop-Anwendung
zu benutzen.
Für GitHub nutze ich tatsächlich sehr gerne
als Green Client Source Tool.
Warum?
Ich mag es.
Ich kann es nachvollziehen, wenn du halt so eine
total verworrene Branch-Struktur hast,
die nicht mehr nachvollziehen kannst,
wie viel wo und wo arbeitet.
Dann sowieso, weil ich da nicht mehr durchblicke.
Die habe ich aber selten. Aber ich mag es einfach,
meine Diffs in dem Moment gerade live
vor mir zu sehen, während ich einfach nur
Zeilen rauspicke, die ich jetzt stageln möchte.
Das ist einfach mein typischer Workflow.
Und das kann man zwar auch machen.
Wenn du jetzt so ein Patch-Add machst,
wenn du einzelne Sachen bloß
einzelne Zeilen bloß addest.
Wenn ich weiß, dass ich jetzt alles oder
einfach nur diverse Dateien, die ich hier drin habe,
direkt komplett stageln und committen und pushen möchte
oder was auch immer damit.
Aber bist du dir da sicher, dass die Version,
die du dann addest, dass das
eine kompilierbare Version ist.
Das ist, wenn du jetzt einzelne Teile vergisst,
die du dann unbedingt mit brauchst.
Entweder du weißt es, du siehst es oder fuck it.
Zwei Ansätze gibt es da.
Und gerade an den Projekten,
in denen ich selbst alleine arbeite,
ist es mir einerseits egal,
ob jeder Commit baubar ist.
Andererseits
mache ich viele Dinge auf einmal oft,
weil ich einfach den Überblick gerade verliere
in meinem Workflow.
Und dann will ich das doch nochmal
mehr oder weniger atomare Commits rauszerren.
Ich habe ja letzte Nacht da gesessen und endlich mal wieder an einer meiner Open-Source-Libraries was gebaut.
Und da ist mir auch mittendrin aufgefallen, ich expose hier einen Error aus Debus,
der eigentlich gar nicht, das gehört ja gar nicht dazu.
Ich benutze hier noch gar nicht diese schöne Error-Chain, Error-Handling-Library.
Dann mache ich das mal.
Das hat zwar mit diesem Feature, an dem ich gerade arbeite, nichts zu tun,
aber das muss ich jetzt endlich mal gemacht werden.
Fängst du halt an, ich kennst du dieses GIF aus Malcolm in the Middle,
wo einer, der Typ nach Hause kommt
und die Glühbirne ist kaputt und dann
geht er einfach ins Regal, wo die Glühbirne
drin ist und dann merkt er, dass es quietscht
und dann
möchte er das Öl holen, dann ist das Öl nicht da
und dann möchte er los zum
Auto rennen und was Neues kaufen
und dann geht das Garagentor nicht auf und dann siehst du
irgendwann fünf Stunden später seine Frau nach Hause kommen
und der liegt gerade unter dem Auto und schaut
aus, weil die Glühbirne kaputt war.
Und so ist es halt manchmal, wenn ich so in meiner Codbals rumwühle,
denke ich mir, das kann ich mal noch bauen und dann ist es mir aber,
weil ich da ein halbes Jahr nicht reingeguckt habe,
noch fünf Sachen passiert, die man jetzt schöner machen kann.
Und dann fange ich erst mal an,
überall Strippen rauszuziehen und dann
so
erholsames Refactoring zu machen.
Das hat ja auch eher was sehr Reinigendes,
muss ich sagen, wenn du hinterher sagen kannst,
so, jetzt kenne ich mich mit dieser Code-Paste wieder aus.
Ich habe überall mal reingeguckt.
Jetzt ist es wieder was, womit ich mich identifizieren kann.
So,
bricht jetzt für Leute.
Das war eigentlich schade.
Ich hatte für die Library auf
This Week in Rust
einen Call for Participation gemacht,
weil so ein Feature gefehlt hat,
das war dieses kleine Notification-Dings.
Das ist dieses Back of Linux
unterstützt, dass man da selber Bilddaten
reinschmeißen kann.
Hier eine Notification mit angezeigt werden.
Genau.
Dann hatte ich aber keine Zeit dafür
und dann habe ich so einen Call for Participation gemacht
und habe das, erzähl mir nicht,
dass das für Mac auch geht, sonst muss ich das noch nachziehen.
Und
da kam einer an und hat gesagt, ja hier,
guck mal, habe ich gebaut,
so lala. Es gibt hier noch ein paar
Sachen, wo ich noch nicht genau weiß,
wie man das schön ziehen kann, weil es unterschiedliche
Specs gibt, die du unterstützen musst.
Das musst du zu irgendeiner Zeit rausfinden, welche
Version du unterstützt.
Ich habe den aber noch dreimal
geschrieben, ja cool, machst du einen Pull-Request raus?
Hallo?
Es ist okay, wenn ich jetzt einfach
deine Changes von deinem Branch pulle?
Hallo?
Und da hat sich keiner beschwert und irgendwann
auch meine Frage, ob ich das jetzt einfach
so übernehmen kann, habe ich zumindest von irgendjemand anders
auf GitHub so einen Daumen hoch.
Da habe ich gedacht, dann mache ich das jetzt einfach. Dann habe ich das
noch adaptiert und
so gemacht, dass ich mir das vorstellen kann.
Und dann
musste ich halt noch ein paar optionale
Features hinzubauen, ein paar optionale
Dependencies hinzubauen, um statische
Anfragen zu machen, welche Version
von der Spec gerade hier verfügbar ist.
Und um Bilddaten
zu pausen, Bilder zu pausen. Also du kannst jetzt
bei der Library ein Bild angeben,
ein Bildpfad, dann macht meine
Library das über das ImageCrate
auf, liest da die
Bilddaten raus und schickt das dann an den Server.
Weil das ist das, was der gebaut hat.
Du könntest also Byte-Vektoren
mit Pixel da reinschreiben.
Das ist das Feature.
Es hat auch eine Schnittstelle, wo du dem
sagen kannst, guck mal, hier ist ein Bild, bettet das mal
in die Notification ein, aber das funktioniert auf keiner der Implementierung.
Okay, schade.
Und irgendwann
habe ich das fertig gebaut
und dann stellt es halt fest,
ach ja, warte mal,
Für Mac muss die Library ja auch funktionieren.
Dann hast du dein Arbeitsgerät aufgeklappt,
und hast du das drauf kombiniert?
Dann habe ich da noch zwei Changes gemacht.
Dann irgendwann
habe ich heute eine neue
meiner Version veröffentlicht.
Schön.
Meine Version, ich habe überlegt,
mache ich jetzt eine Major-Version draus.
Ich habe ja schließlich dieses Error-Handling
da mittendrin auch noch ausgetauscht
und aufgeräumt.
Ordentlich.
Semba würde es von dir verlangen.
Ja.
Nee.
Es ist kompatibel.
Ach so, okay.
Und ich habe aber auf Crate.io,
da möchte ich eigentlich mal ein Skript für schreiben.
Ich habe alle Dependent-Crates rausgesucht,
also Reverse Dependencies,
und habe die alle mal runtergezogen.
26.
Ja, okay.
Und habe die alle mal gegen die neue Version gebaut und gesehen.
Schön.
So was ist doch toll, wenn man das einfach mal machen kann.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Und dafür hätte ich kein Skript.
Das müsste eigentlich relativ einfach sein.
Du sagst hier, das ist mein Crate.
gebe ich mal alle Dependencies, gebe ich mal dazu die Repos,
klone die mal, mache mal die Cargo-Tommel
auf, suche mal meine Dependency,
füge mal da, steht das in diesem Pfad ein
und dann bauen wir alle.
Ein See-If-This-Still-Works-Zierei-Tool.
Sowas hat,
sowas macht Rust ja selber.
Ich weiß, dass die sehr viel
gegen Crates, öffentliche Crates,
eben bauen und testen und schauen.
Swift hat ja auch vor kurzem die Swift-Compatibility-Suite
gestartet.
Was ist es, Suite oder Suite?
Ich kenne beide.
Aussprichvarianten?
Jetzt bin ich verwirrt.
Mach weiter.
Eine gute Frage. Ich sage ja immer
Suit, weil ich einfach so, also
Suit ist ja das, was man anzieht,
aber ich glaube, ich würde auch die Suit mit E
am Ende jetzt...
Egal. Das werde ich nach dieser Folge
rausfinden.
Die haben die Swift Compatibility
S-U-I-T-E
ins Leben gerufen, wo die
größere Swift-Projekte,
die existieren, da jemand reinziehen und die
automatisch ist Teil ihres SIA-Prozesses mit
bauen gegen Swift-Changes.
Finde ich sehr cool. Und die akzeptieren
auch neue Projekte mit rein. Ich weiß nicht,
in welchem Umfang. Also die versuchen natürlich,
das möglichst so
zu halten, dass es nicht unmaintainable
wird. Und wenn du dir jetzt irgendwie, ich ziehe
ein Swift-Package mit rein und das baut auf dem anderen
auf und das andere liegt dabei auch schon drin,
dann kann ich das andere auch streichen, weil das da ja sowieso mit
gebaut wird.
Da halt ein bisschen sinnvoll ist anzugehen.
Aber ich finde es eine coole Sache und auch echt stark,
dass die damit drauf schauen.
Ich habe in den letzten Tagen gar nicht mehr reingeschaut, ob da noch irgendwas
groß dazugekommen ist. Die hatten ein paar sehr bekannte Projekte,
unter anderem auch SwiftLint gleich am Anfang mit dabei.
Finde ich eine coole Sache.
Da habe ich schon mal gehört gehabt, dass die das genauso machen.
Das gefällt mir.
Gibt es sowas für andere Sprachen eigentlich?
Für Kotlin oder so?
Das ist gerade auf Kotlin umlenkend.
Ich kenne mich in der Kotlin-Welt
nicht so gut aus, dass ich sagen könnte, da existiert sowas.
stark davon aus, dass andere Sprachen auch solche.
Es ist bloß, weil jetzt Kotlin ja in letzter Zeit
wieder so ein bisschen ins Gespräch
gekommen ist. So ein bisschen.
Das hat einen mega Push bekommen durch
Google zu Google I.O.
Die haben auch mir auf der I.O. gesagt, so übrigens, wir unterstützen
jetzt auch Kotlin.
Unterstützt wurde
das ja schon vorher. Also du konntest ja
dadurch, dass der TVM basiert ist und auch Interop
mit Java hat, problemlos Android
Apps in Kotlin schreiben. Aber jetzt ist es
offiziell und Beispielcode ist
in Kotlin und die Docs sind mit Kotlin-Samples
und Android Studio hat
direkt, wenn du eine neue
App anlegst, wahrscheinlich
Kotlin-Kram mit drin. Finde ich
echt cool. Ich fand es ein bisschen witzig, dass
Leute gesagt haben, ja, boah, das ist toll von Google,
dass sie das jetzt machen. Aber eigentlich
ist das eine Sprache, die von JetBrains entwickelt wurde
und die haben hier ganz große Vorarbeiter geleistet.
Ja, natürlich. Da reinge ich das Android Studio auch
ein JetBrains-Produkt. Ja, klar. Android Studio
ist IntelliJ, bloß mit ein bisschen
anderem Branding.
Ja, aber ich finde es was interessant von Google, dass sie das da mit reingenommen haben.
Das ist eine starke Sache.
Es ist natürlich mal angenehm zu sehen, dass sich da was tut
und wir coole neue Sprachen auch haben.
Und Google nicht aus Versehen auf die Idee gekommen ist,
dass doch Go die neue Android-Sprache ist.
Oh Gott.
Das wäre aber auch gar nicht mal so unrealistisch gewesen.
Nee, viele Leute hatten nämlich auch spekuliert, dass sowas kommt.
Nachdem eine Zeit lang Leute versucht haben, Scala als neue Android-Sprache zu pushen.
Ja, 2016 ist das Jahr von Scala auf Android.
nicht.
Aber ganz ehrlich, ich saß irgendwann,
wo war ich da? Letztes Jahr war ich beim
Java User Group Treffen,
Java User Group Saxony
Tag. Das war glaube ich
der letzte Tag, wo ich als Student war.
Da bin ich noch als Student kostenlos reingekommen.
Das war sehr witzig.
Und da habe ich auch Vorträge
über moderne funktionale Sprachen
auf der JVM gehört. Da habe ich mir tatsächlich mal
einen Vortrag über Scala reingezogen, weil ich vorher noch nie was
mit Scala mehr anguckt habe.
Und da habe ich gedacht, ah, das Konzept und das Konzept
Scala ist ja fast wie Rust.
Scala ist aber
wirklich mehr funktional ausgelegt, oder?
Also Rust hat ja auch genau wie Swift
funktionaler Elemente, aber keine funktionale Sprache.
Das ist
von der Funktionalität
her. Von der Funktionalness
her.
Funktionalness.
Sind die beiden
Sprachen eigentlich ziemlich gleich auf.
Beide haben so ein Konzept von Trails,
was relativ ähnlich ist.
Sie haben beide Pattern Matching,
Die haben sehr viele Sprachkonzepte,
die beide identisch haben.
Und danach saß ich in einem Vortrag über Kotlin,
die neue coole Sprache, die auf die JVM jetzt war.
Da dachte ich mir, hey, warte mal,
ich habe gerade einen Vortrag über Scala gehört.
Das sah alles viel geiler aus,
als was du mir gerade über Kotlin erzählst.
Vielleicht einfach nur, weil deine Definition von geil
ein bisschen in eine funktionalere Richtung da geht.
Wahrscheinlich.
Kotlin ist ganz schick, finde ich.
Scala ist auch schick und macht ja auch keinen Unterschied.
du kannst ja deine Android-App schreiben, was immer du möchtest,
solange es JVM-basiert ist, dann hast du ja
alle Möglichkeiten. Ja, Skala ist schon
so ein bisschen verschrieben, weil es auch viel zu langsam
kompiliert, glaube ich.
Aber nein, die Compile-Zeiten sind relativ wurscht.
Die sind natürlich ein bisschen schön zu haben,
starke Compile-Zeiten, aber gerade von
dem RAS-Developer jetzt zu hören, dass eine Compile-Zeit
wichtig ist.
Das ist halt immer drauf an, was
passiert.
Auf Arbeit merke ich, dass ich
TypeScript kompiliere
und das dauert lange.
Okay. Und dann musst du es testen
und dann funktioniert es trotzdem nicht.
Du kompilierst es ja auch und danach interpretierst du es nochmal.
Das ist ja immer so.
Ja, aber der
Wenn ich jetzt Rust schreibe
und ich habe auch Mist gebaut, dann muss ich
nicht warten, bis es zu Ende kompiliert hat.
Dann knallt es sofort beim Kompilieren meistens.
Bei TypeScript,
das Typsystem ist ja nicht Sound.
Da kannst du halt Sachen
bauen, die hinterher trotzdem kaputt sind.
Das stimmt.
Also gut liegende Runtime-Fehler
auftreten, die du bei
Swift und Rust wahrscheinlich schneller merken würdest.
Und da habe ich
mir aber auch mal aufgefallen, dass das ganz schön lange dauert.
War das auch bei einem Projekt
bei einem kleinen
so ein paar Sekunden, bis es
kombiniert hat und es geht nicht einfach mal
so eben durch.
Und bei einem größeren, es ist schon
einigermaßen schmerzhaft.
Und dann merkst du, musst du es trotzdem noch Runtime testen.
Das ist schon... Ja, das ist eklig.
Compiler sind was Schönes. Ich freue mich
darüber, dass die Leute jetzt richtig tolle
coole Compiler, immer mehr schreiben.
Also gerade der Rust-Compiler ist ja schon episch,
aber dann schau dir mal das Wunder an,
was Elm auf die Beine gestellt hat.
Das steht immer noch auf meiner To-Learn-List.
Da kannst du ja programmieren lernen,
allein anhand der Compiler-Fehlermeldung.
Das ist ja...
Eigentlich wäre es genau richtig, wenn du anfängst,
was hinzuschreiben, wie du es dir jetzt denkst,
ohne dass du die Sprache kennst und der Compiler sagt,
nee, so geht das nicht, mach mal so.
Und wenn es dann kompiziert, hast du die Sprache gelernt.
Oh, geil.
Genauso stelle ich mir das vor. Wunderschön.
Ja, aber es gibt ja noch, du kannst ja
mal ganz kurz den Bogen zurückzuschlagen,
die JVM ist ja schon recht dick,
also du kannst ja in verschiedensten Sprachen,
ich habe mal in Closure eine winzig kleine
Android-App versucht zu bauen,
das war ein witziges Projekt
für einen Samstag,
aber ich meine, abgesehen davon, dass ich keine Android kann
und zu der Zeit sehr wenig Closure konnte und
wahrscheinlich immer noch genau auf dem selben Level von Closure bin.
Wie weit bist du gekommen?
Nicht allzu weit, aber mit Closure habe ich mega viel Spaß gehabt,
das ist eine unglaublich coole Sprache.
Ich finde, ich mag Lisp,
Dialekte, die sind syntaktisch so
klein.
Ja,
gegen eine kleine Syntax kann man
nichts sagen, muss ich sagen.
Ja, aber du hast, ich finde,
es ist angenehm, eine JVM zu haben,
wenn du darauf aufbauen kannst, weil dann hast du
viel mehr Möglichkeiten, habe ich das Gefühl,
als wenn du es anders angehst, dann hast du diesen
Interop auch zwischen Sprachen richtig geil da.
Du kannst, dependenz, diesen anderen
Sprachen einfach reinzunehmen mit dem Sprechen, kein Problem.
Das ist einfach ein cooles Feature.
Jede Sprache baut Interop zu den Sprachen,
zu denen es kompatibel sein möchte.
Ja klar.
Also die ganzen Microsoft-Sprachen
haben alle.NET-Interop miteinander.
Du meinst CIS und FIS?
CIS und FIS und PLANG,
was sie jetzt rausgebracht haben.
Das ist PLANG?
Ja, PLANG.
Die haben irgendwie eine neue Programmier-Sprache rausgebracht,
die P heißt.
Okay.
Und dann, ja, die sind alle.NET-kompatibel.
Dann gibt es die ganzen Sprachen,
die C-kompatibel sind,
dann gibt es Swift,
was versucht,
Objective-C-kompatibel zu sein.
Und es ist...
Mehr oder weniger.
Es gibt ja so ein paar Stellen,
wo es immer wieder spaßig kaputt geht.
Zumindest ist mir aufgefallen,
dass es jetzt so ein paar Seiten aufkam,
wo Leute darauf hinweisen wollten.
Hier übrigens,
Kotlin ist gar nicht so neu.
Kotlin ist like Swift.
Und dann gab es noch eine schöne Vergleichsseite,
Syntax links und Syntax rechts.
Einmal Kotlin, einmal Swift und dann gab es das
eine hier und eine da. Und was war das andere?
Kotlin ist like TypeScript.
Das war fast schon ein bisschen
weiter, muss ich sagen, weil da waren die Unterschiede
jetzt nicht so. Aber gerade so ein Hello World
sieht ja an den meisten Sprachen einigermaßen ähnlich aus.
Das stimmt.
Und gerade bei den Sprachen, wo du keinen
Einsprungspunkt hast, wo du keine Main
Funktion brauchst oder sowas, ist ja bei Swift
auch so, witzigerweise.
Ja.
Wir hatten ja für das ASCII dieses
eine Repo gemacht, wo die ganzen Kaffeesorten
sind und jede Kaffeesorte ist ja
eine Programmiersprache und dann ist die Kaffeesorte
ein kleines Hello World
in der Programmiersprache, was den
Namen der Kaffeesorte und
den Preis ausgibt.
Die Leute, die es nicht wissen, hier könntest du uns herkommen und
an der Kaffeemaschine ein C++ bestellen
oder ein Swift oder
oder ein Java oder ein Lua
oder ein Haskell oder ein Rust
oder ein Assembler.
Und dann, das ist aber ein bisschen enttäuschend,
ich dachte mir, ich mache jetzt mal zu jeder
Kaffeesorte in der Programmiersprache so ein kleines
Es war halt ein bisschen durchschnittlich zu sehen,
dass in vielen Sprachen die Hello Worlds halt exakt identisch sind.
Es ist zwischen Swift und Python
gibt keinen Unterschied.
Print, Klammer auf,
String, Klammer zu.
Das Schwierigste war eigentlich noch Assembler,
weil da gab es eigentlich keine Gemeinsamkeit
zwischen unterschiedlichen Sprachen.
Dann hast du auch irgendwelche Bibliotheken drin,
die nicht bauen.
Dann Objective-C ging nicht, um da eine Version zu bauen,
die auch noch auf Linux funktioniert.
Dann hättest du es gleich im C schreiben können.
Wir haben uns auch Mühe gegeben
mit den Kaffeenamenzuordnungen
zu den jeweiligen Kaffeesorten, dass die halt
halbwegs sinnvoll sind.
Beispiel
Assembler ist halt
heißes Wasser, weil das steckt ja überall drin.
Unser Heskel ist der Tee,
weil der ist ein ganz anderes
koffeinhaltiges Getränk.
Und Heskel gibt es auch.
Kaffee ist einfach nur C.
Kaffee, einfach Kaffee, ganz einfach,
kennt jeder, ist auch überall
die Basis.
Genau, Wasser ist
dann Cappuccino
ist Python, solide,
verbreitet, gut,
ist ein Klassiker.
Der Milchkaffee war der Java, oder?
Milchkaffee ist Java,
das habe ich hier,
das haben wir schon immer getrunken, das werden wir
auch weiter trinken. Ist besonders in
Deutschland sehr verbreitet und beliebt.
Oder kann es sein, dass Java
einfach in Deutschland eine große Verbreitung hat
und in anderen Ländern schon wieder gar nicht mehr so sehr.
Die Sprache?
Ja.
Das wären wahrscheinlich irgendwelche Beises,
die wir jetzt auch versuchen irgendwie rauszuziehen.
Nicht irgendeinen Whitespace-Witz noch mit Python mit drin?
Aber weiß ich gerade nicht mehr.
Haben wir einen Whitespace?
Nee.
Das wäre dann eine leere Tasse, oder was?
Den Witz zu vollenden,
unsere Kaffeemaschine hat einen Eimer,
in den sie das Abwasser reinspült
und das ist das PHP.
Ich habe gestern einen ziemlich guten Vortrag gesehen
von Ashley Williams auf dem Rust-Fest
in Kiew, wie man Leute
wie du deine Firma davon
überzeugst, dass sie Rust benutzen soll.
Okay. Und das waren
dann zehn ziemlich gute
Techniken. Einfach
so, erstens schreib mich alles komplett
neu. Wenn du davon
erzählst,
dann bring doch schon mal was mit. Du musst schon ein bisschen
in Vorleistung gehen, was zeigen, aber immer was einzelne
Teile austauschen, weil es zu teuer ist
oder zu gefährlich für die Firma.
Wenn Leute versuchen mit einzusteigen,
dann wird konkret, aber wenn diese
lernen wollen, dann haue ich
nicht bei kleinen Fehlern auf die Finger, sondern lasse ich
erstmal selber rausfinden und
bäsche nicht andere Sprachen,
weil damit stellt man eigentlich nicht cool da.
Das soll ich mir auch oft im Meistbeispiel
bäsche zu kennen.
Ich mag auch gerne Sprachen zu vergleichen.
Mit der anderen Seite
muss ich mich auch mal zusammenreißen, über
Go rum zu bäschen.
Achso, in so einem Kaffee-Vipo gibt es da immer noch den Preis für die Person,
die das CoffeeScript-Make-File zum Laufen bekommt für alles?
Gibt es das nicht mittlerweile schon?
Aber das baut nicht alles.
Es gibt ein Make-File. Gilbert hat ein Make-File gebaut.
Aber das kriegt nicht alles hin.
Nee, es geht ja auch nicht. Es gibt ja auch nicht eine Plattform,
wo alle diese Sachen gleichzeitig laufen.
Also Swift kannst du zwar mittlerweile, aber Objective-C kannst du nur auf Mac bauen.
Auf Mac kannst du aber dafür kein... Was war das andere bauen?
Das eine Assembly, was wir da haben.
Das ist eine Assembler, also das ist wirklich nur...
Ach, das ist ja lahm.
Ich dachte, das kriegt man irgendwie schön unter einen Hut.
Ja.
Du wolltest ja eh eine CoffeeScript-Make-File eigentlich,
weil wir ja ein Kaffee sind.
Cake-File heißt das.
Oh Gott, das ist wirklich Cake-File.
Ich habe jetzt mal wieder mit CoffeeScript rumgespielt.
Okay, inwiefern?
Und zwar habe ich ja dieses eine Spiel,
was wir in der letzten Folge erwähnt haben,
mal wieder angefasst.
Das habe ich vor fünf Jahren das letzte Mal was dran gemacht.
Eigentlich ist CoffeeScript wirklich tot.
Und ich dachte, eigentlich möchte ich das mal auf modernere Beine stellen.
Ich habe jetzt irgendwie auch wieder mehr mit JavaScript zu tun.
Und könnte ich eigentlich das mal ein bisschen so als Übungsvorlage nehmen,
um ein bisschen meine Skills mal wieder zu schärfen.
Das Erste, was ich gemacht habe, ist, dass ich das irgendwie von diesem alten,
selbst gekrüppelten Bildsystem umgefriemelt habe auf MPM.
Vorher war das mit einem Make-File zusammengebaut,
was dann das ganze Coffee-Script
kompiliert hat und dann zusammengeschmissen hat.
Und es basierte auf,
es gab ja für den Browser noch nicht wirklich so etwas wie
Require, wie es das in Node gibt.
Dann habe ich
Require.js verwendet.
Da musstest du so einen übelsten Kopf bauen,
der dann alle Includes geholt hat
und der das dann in einem weiteren langwierigen Compile-Schritt
dann zu einer Datei zusammengebaut hat.
Das war das Erste, was rausgeflogen ist.
Mein Plan war eigentlich, das mittelfristig
nach TypeScript zu portieren.
Und das ist dadurch möglich, dass ich das
mit Webpack jetzt baue.
Webpack sagst du...
Mein erster Gedanke war,
Webpack ist was, was einfach
viele Dateien nimmt
und zu einer Datei zusammenkloppt.
Was ja schon mal
nicht dumm ist. Da dachte ich, vielleicht kann man das hier mal
verwenden. Da ist mir aufgefallen, dass du Webpack
Du kannst übrigens Sachen, die TS heißen,
jagse mal bitte durch den TypeScript-Compiler
und machst JavaScript raus.
Und Sachen, die TSX heißen, sind übrigens React
und jagse dadurch.
Und Sachen, die Coffee heißen,
jagse bitte durch CoffeeScript.
Und dann habe ich gedacht,
naja, vielleicht kann ich einfach das CoffeeScript
nehmen, einmal nach JavaScript kompilieren
und das dann irgendwie
noch nach TypeScript
portieren. Also das ist viel zu eklig,
weil das JavaScript, was aus CoffeeScript
rausfällt, ist halt nicht
schön. Die haben ja
viel schönere
Schleifenkonstrukte
in CoffeeScript als
viel schönere
Callback-Syntax
in CoffeeScript als in JavaScript.
Und du hattest auch in CoffeeScript als erstes Klassen,
bevor du es in JavaScript hattest.
Und das JavaScript, was CoffeeScript produziert,
ist halt ziemlich eklig,
weil es diese ganzen Konzepte halt wieder
rausnimmt und was baut, was
JavaScript vor fünf Jahren oder sechs Jahren hatte.
mir ist aber in dem Zuge aufgefallen, es gibt CoffeeScript 2
das ist bis jetzt eine Alpha oder eine Beta
und das produziert zumindest
als Output
ECMAScript 6
das heißt, da sind dann Klassen drin
und da habe ich das einfach mal eingeschaltet
und dann habe ich zwei Sachen portiert
und dann konnte ich schon, weil es nämlich auch
Import, Export
und Module
included plötzlich in der Syntax
konnte ich überall ganz normal wie in einem modernen
JavaScript reinschreiben, import this, export
this und dann habe ich erstmal
das require.js rausgeschmissen
und jetzt kann ich
Webpack sagen, guck mal da, diese ganzen JavaScript-Dateien,
die inkluden sich, äh, diese ganzen
JavaScript-Dateien, die inkluden sich gegenseitig.
Bau das mal zusammen.
Ziemlich schick. Und das nächste, was
dadurch möglich ist, dass ich sage,
der
hat so eine Liste von Dateiendungen,
tsjs,
tsxcoffee
und die geht da der Reihe nach durch. Und wenn er
Datei findet, die mehrmals da ist,
zum Beispiel in meinem Spiel habe ich so ein Graph-Lobic
implementiert, wenn der jetzt Graph
JS findet, dann nimmt
er als erstes das nicht, weil in der Liste
taucht das hinter Coffee auf, er kompiliert
dann die Coffee-Version rein. Wenn du allerdings
in deine Liste vor Coffee
noch TS schreibst, in der dann eine
TypeScript-Variante findet, dann nimmt er die.
Das heißt, ich kann die Datei,
das ganze Modul, wie es ist,
rüber abschreiben,
portieren und dann habe ich zumindest, das kann ich
Stück für Stück, modulweise
das Ding von
CoffeeScript nach TypeScript portieren und wenn ich will,
kann ich Sachen in CoffeeScript lassen.
So ist es momentan.
Das ist eigentlich schon ziemlich nice.
Das ist echt angenehm, muss ich sagen.
Und weil du jetzt gesagt hast, naja,
Scala kompiliert das und
interpretiert es dann bloß trotzdem.
Wo hatten wir das?
Das hatten wir mit TypeScript.
Im Endeffekt ist es ja bei anderen Sprachen
genauso.
Bei Java-Sprachen
ist es so, dass die HLT alle in diesen
Java-Byte-Code kompilieren.
Bei
LLVM-Sprachen kompilieren sie alle
nach LLVM und zum Schluss nach Assembler.
Bei.NET-Sprachen
kompilieren sie alle nach.NET und hier
kompilieren sie alle nach einfaches JavaScript.
Die Lingua Franca
der Programmiersprachen.
Ja, du möchtest nicht zum Schluss alles nach
JavaScript
portieren, aber mit Webpack
kannst du halt sagen, hier
mein Projekt, das zum Schluss kommt überall
Script raus oder JavaScript-kompatibel ist.
Und dann kannst du deine einzelnen Module in Sachen
schreiben, die das als Target
haben. Du hast dann Loader für
unterschiedliche Sprachen. Ich muss halt so noch eine Dependency
TypeScript-Loader hinzufügen und CoffeeScript-Loader.
Und dann kommt aber eine große
lange JavaScript dabei heraus und der macht das auch
schicker parallel. Also Watching funktioniert
leider nicht mehr, dass du, wenn ich eine Datei ändere,
dass er dann nur die Datei kompiliert.
Weil er es eh immer
in eine Datei zusammenschmeißt.
Aber ich habe dadurch zum Beispiel
auch die Möglichkeit, mal eben noch eine neue
eine neue Sprache hinzuzufügen.
Also ich könnte zum Beispiel Teile der Logik in Rust
schreiben und das dann
mit... Das ist dann kompiliert.
Genau, und das dann mit
Skripten oder WebAssembly da reinschmeißen.
Und das ist eigentlich
ganz cool.
Ein Projekt, was so aus 20 verschiedenen Sprachen
besteht und auch gleichzeitig alles benutzt.
Also ganz ehrlich, ich lese mir diesen Code durch.
Ich habe mich damals, als ich den geschrieben habe,
gefreut, dass CoffeeScript halt eine Sprache ist,
wo da mal eben irgendwas im Clear ist.
Aber JS ist ja noch scheiße.
Damals war JS ja noch richtig eklig.
Aber selbst in JavaScript wäre es jetzt eklig,
weil du hast halt keine Typen. Du liest dir
diesen Code durch, ich schmeiße da irgendwas zusammen,
das sind Objekte, da stehen drei Sachen drin,
dann habe ich mir aber auch nichts
dabei gedacht und den halt kurze
Variablen-Namen gegeben
und dann macht der da halt Graflogik drauf
und das ist so ein Zyklen-Finder-Algorithmus,
der irgendwelche Zwischenergebnisse
hat. Ich lese mir da durch,
was ich geschrieben habe, versteht er selber nicht mehr.
Meine Vorstellung ist, wenn ich da Typen drin hätte,
dann könnte ich jetzt wesentlich besser nachvollziehen,
Vor allem auch, was gibt dieses Ding raus?
Das allerwichtigste
bei einer getypten Sprache ist
im ersten Schritt, im Gegensatz zu
wie es bei JavaScript und bei Ruby und bei Python
ist, wenn ich mir das durchlese
und ich sehe eine Funktion,
dann nicht nur, dass ich nicht sehe,
was für Typen die Parameter
haben, die da reinkommen,
sondern ich sehe den Funktionen nicht mal an,
ob die was zurückgeben oder nicht.
Das weißt du einfach nicht.
Gib die nur was zurück, gib die nicht was zurück,
dann suchst du und dann hast du da irgendwo
ein Return drinsteht, aber nee, es ist ja CoffeeScript.
CoffeeScript verhält sich wie Ruby,
das heißt, das Letzte, was du rausgibst,
ist ein Return. Dann habe ich mir
das Kompilat dazu angeguckt, dass
das JavaScript rausfällt
und da steht überall Return drin,
obwohl ich das teilweise gar nicht
benutze. Das schmeißt CoffeeScript da einfach mit
rein, weil das Letzte, was du machst, wird halt zurückgegeben.
Und es ist auch
total sinnlos, diese Aussage.
Es ist echt schwer, den Code zu verstehen
und zu interpretieren als Mensch.
Genau. Und ich bin da nochmal drüber gegangen und habe dann halt versucht, so rekursive Aufrufe und Schleifen nach TypeScript abzuschreiben, weil das, was das, ja, da habe ich ja schon festgestellt, eigentlich hat CoffeeScript schon seine Berechtigung.
Du kannst halt schon wesentlich schöner und angenehmer hinschreiben, was du machen möchtest.
Zum einen hast du unless, was viele logische Ausdrücke ein bisschen klarer macht, anstatt if not.
Dann kannst du für kurze logische Ausdrücke kannst du die in so einer Suffix-Syntax wie in Ruby schreiben.
Also do this unless that oder do this if that auf eine Zeile.
Das kannst du mit TypeScript auch noch nicht machen.
Eigentlich ist TypeScript nur schön, weil du Typen hast.
In dem Moment ist mir eingefallen, eigentlich bräuchtest du
getyptes Coffee-Script.
Die Typen sind schön.
Das wäre richtig, richtig geil.
Typen sind nicht nur für Compiler, Typen sind auch für Menschen da.
Nee, Typen sind vornehmlich für Menschen da.
Das ist echt angenehm zu wissen, zu sehen, zu lesen.
Zu sehen, was gibt das Ding zurück?
Was ist das? Ist das hier das Gleiche wie das?
Oder ist das was anderes?
Und ein JavaScript ist halt alles entweder eine Nummer
oder ein String oder ein Objekt.
Das ist schon eklig.
Es gibt ja auch viele Freiheiten.
Manche Leute stehen halt auf diese Freiheiten.
Ja, man kann mal eben schnell
was hinschreiben und
das stimmt schon nicht. Ich habe gestern
mal wieder diesen Pull Request in Rust gemacht,
da habe ich festgestellt, dass du halt für Kleinigkeiten
ewig brauchst.
Aber das ist halt
eine Fehleinschätzung.
Du brauchst halt am Anfang ewig
und wenn es
soweit ist, dass es kompiliert, bist du
soweit es geht fertig.
Bei CoffeeScript oder bei JavaScript schreibst du schnell was hin
und dann änderst du das aber noch 10 Mal und testest
das noch 10 Mal zur Laufzeit.
Du steckst die Zeit ins Debuggen,
die du halt vorher nicht...
Genau, du steckst die Zeit ins Testen und ins Debuggen,
anstatt ins Kompilieren.
Also wirklich eine Verschiebung auf der Skala.
Die Zeit, die man jetzt nicht braucht, was zu entwickeln,
bleibt grob die gleiche überhaupt nicht einfach mal.
Und das ist...
Es gab ein schönes Buch, das wurde mir in diesem
Code-Podcast mal schmackhaft gemacht.
Kennst du den Code-Podcast?
Das ist von diesem einen Russen,
da ist immer dieser total schicke Jazz unten drunter.
Ein schöner Podcast.
Richtig gut.
Code.
Und es gibt ein schönes Buch,
das heißt Type-Driven Development.
Okay.
Das heißt,
ich fange nicht an,
die Algorithmen hinzuschreiben,
sondern ich definiere erst mal die Typen,
wie die miteinander in Italien.
Und so machst du das halt,
wenn du eine typisierte Sprache hast.
Bei JavaScript und bei nicht typisierten Sprachen
ist deine Herangehensweise eine ganz andere,
mehr da du anfängst,
deine Prototypen hinzuschreiben.
Da machst du erst mal,
was irgendwas zusammenbaut,
irgendwas rausgibt,
irgendwas annimmt, vielleicht nicht zurückgibt,
vielleicht was zurückgibt.
Und dann hast du halt verwurstelten Code hinterher.
Und wenn du allerdings an Typen denkst,
und das versuche ich, wenn ich TypeScript mache, als erstes zu machen,
dass ich mir halt echt erst Interfaces und Classes
hinschreibe und die dann annehme und nicht annehme,
dann
hast du
von Anfang an eine viel verständlichere,
klarere Struktur in deinem Programm.
Das macht auch
Refactoring wesentlich einfacher. Also Refactoring
auf einer nicht typisierten Sprache ist
ein Kraus. Weil ich weiß nicht,
wenn ich hier was ändere,
wo hat das noch Nebenwirkungen?
Bei einer typisierten Sprache,
selbst bei TypeScript ist es so,
dass mir die IDE sagt, wenn ich diesen Parameter
wegnehme, fällt es da, da und dort um.
Es gibt ja teilweise
Leute, die schreiben in
JavaScript-Funktionen hin, die überhaupt keine
Parameter annehmen und arbeiten dann intern
mit dieser Arguments-Variable.
Ja, aber man schmeißt einfach noch mehr
Sicherheiten weg. Klar, warum nicht?
Man braucht schon Rückgabe,
Werte und Parameter.
Du musst schon wissen, was eine
Funktion annimmt.
Super eklig.
Ich liebe das auch. Als allererstes definiere ich mir immer schöne
Inam-Werte und Typen und alles.
Das ist auch der spaßigste Teil
davon, wenn ich eine kleine Library schreibe.
Das ist ein warmes Gefühl, wenn ich mir erst mal saubere Typen
definiere.
Mir kann keiner mehr erzählen, dass nicht typisierte
Sprachen in größeren Projekten
einen Sinn haben.
Deswegen haben die Leute
TypeScript erfunden.
ein TypeScript geht immer noch nicht weit genug.
Es muss aber halt, es kann nicht so weit gehen,
wie es mag, weil du halt mit JavaScript
reden möchtest. Und wenn du halt
JavaScript-Libraries reinziehst, die ja keine Typen haben,
dann musst du halt auch darüber umgehen können, dass Dinge
keine Typen haben. Du musst halt dann anfangen, Dinge
leicht zu annotieren. Das geht nicht.
Du musst sie ja dann leicht annotieren.
Für solche Sachen gibt es dieses
Types-Projekt oder
Definitely Typed.
Da hast du für,
zum Beispiel, wenn du Node.js
mit TypeScript machst, dann hast du ja
selbst für die gesamte Node-Standard-Bibliothek
ist ja nicht getypt.
Was machst du denn da? Du hast ja potenziell überall
Fehler. Also ziehst du dir erstmal die Dependency
Types Node.js runter
und das sind
Typ-Definitionen für die
gesamte Standard-Bibliothek.
Du kannst auch für andere existierende JavaScript-Projekte,
die ja Typ-Definitionen nachträglich runterladen,
die halt nicht innerhalb
von dieser Dependency dann
dafür sorgen, dass die richtig ist, aber wenn die
sauber darauf mappen, dann sagen dir,
dir wenigstens, dass du die Library
richtig verwendest, die du gerade reinziehst.
Oh Gott, und wenn die Version von denen nicht übereinstimmt,
dann komme ich in ganz witzige Gefilde.
Ja, dann benutzt du halt
eventuell zu wenig Feature von deiner
Library oder
veraltete Feature, das stimmt.
Klingt ja
unglaublich spaßig. Aber cool.
Ich meine, das klingt ja
ganz gut. Die Type-Flip-Welt ist auch
gut am florieren.
Coole Sprache.
Schick.
macht Spaß. Bei uns hat neulich einer
im internen Slack gepostet, guck mal, ich habe
jetzt diese drei
Überladungen einer Funktion
geschrieben und zum Schluss, wenn ich das jetzt ausführe,
wird die falsche genommen, habe ich jetzt TypeScript kaputt
gemacht. Okay, wie ist das
passiert? Das kann dir halt,
wer hat da eine Variante genommen,
die nimmt als Parameter eine Zahl an,
die zweite nimmt einen String an und die dritte
nimmt so einen SumType an,
also String
oder Number
TypeScript für was anderes entschieden, als er dachte.
Aber gut, an der Stelle ist er schon mal echt schwierig, daran festzumachen.
Das liegt halt daran, dass du, dass das
Typsystem von dieser Sprache nicht...
Was würde denn ein anderes Typsystem an
so einer Stelle eben machen, wo er wüsste?
Der würde dir sagen Ambiguity? Ja, eben.
Der würde das um die Ohren werfen und sagen, hey, so kann ich das hier
nicht. Der Overload ist nicht akzeptabel, der dritte.
Genau.
Aber ein schönes Feature von TypeScript,
was zum Beispiel Rust nicht hat, ist, du kannst ja nicht nur
algebraische Datentypen haben,
sondern du kannst auch Strings
als Sum-Typen haben. Also du kannst
sagen, diese Variable, die kann nur
drei Zustände annehmen. Ich diesen String, diesen String
oder diesen String. Du kannst alle möglichen Zustände
davon vorher schon angeben und das als
für Strings. Da war ich auch überrascht. Das habe ich mal
in einem Blogpost gelesen von Ben.
Genau darüber, dass der halt so
Compile-Side-String-Werte tatsächlich
mit analysieren kann. Das ist schon ein bisschen krass
und cool gewesen. Aber zumindest die Aussage,
auf die ich schon seit drei Themen wechseln,
die No-Screen wollte, ist,
du kannst ja sagen, du kompilierst
es weg, aber zum Schluss ist es bei
jeder dieser Sprachen so, dass du
immer auf was weniger Strenges
runterkompilierst. Selbst bei Rust
kompilierst du auf Assembler runter.
Bei
den JVM-Sprachen auf diesen Bytecode,
da hast du auch kein Typ System mehr drin.
Da kannst du dann innen drin rumeditieren
und dann machst du halt Sachen kaputt, die du in einem Level
oben drüber gefangen hättest.
Bei TypeScript kompilierst du auf JavaScript
runter, da hast du dann auch diese Garantien
weggemacht. Aber wenn du das, was
dein Kompilat...
Wenn du das nicht mehr anfasst,
dann
und sowas macht dir witzigerweise
Webpack, das hasht
deinen Code und sagt dir dann,
das basiert auf dieser Code-Version.
Okay, dass du nicht aus Versehen noch Changes
im JavaScript machst, die dir halt deinen Compiler
gefangen hätte, aber du hast es trotzdem gemacht.
Ja, genau.
Cool. Ich meine, klar, der Compiler,
dem muss ich vertrauen, wenn der halt beschissenen Code-Männer
erzeugt, dann
selten sind es Compiler-Fehler.
die letzten ist schon wieder ein bisschen her. Ich saß mal im FVSR-Büro,
hab ein bisschen Swift gecodet und plötzlich
drüber rumgegangen, oh, der Compiler ist gesackvoll.
Dann kommt Simon zu mir her. Nein, dein Code
ist gesackvoll. Nein, der fucking
Compiler ist gesackvoll. Das ist an meinem Code.
Kennst du das, wenn du Podcasts
hörst und du hörst irgendwie eine Stelle
nochmal oder so und dir fällt
dann ein, wo du warst,
als du diesen Podcast,
diese Stelle das letzte Mal gehört hast?
Also ich hab manchmal so Situationen, dass ich
eine Folge nochmal
höre und dann weiß ich genau,
ich war an der Bushaltestelle, als ich diese Stelle
nochmal gehört habe. Okay, ich verbinde
Filme mit Essen, aber
das war ich derzeit gegessen, als ich
den Film geschaut habe. Okay,
aber mir ist zumindest gerade eingefallen,
ich wollte jetzt ansprechen, na klar, weil
Swift ja in C++ geschrieben ist
und es ist ja, wir müssen es mal in Swift
schreiben und ich habe genau
das Thema in unserem
Podcast bei der Kontroll,
bei dem Kontrollhören gehört,
weil wir schon mal darüber gesprochen haben
Und mir ist gerade eingefallen, wo ich unseren eigenen Podcast gehört habe.
Wo ich war, als ich unseren eigenen Podcast gehört habe.
Bei dem Thema, bei dem wir gerade sind.
Boah, das ist nicht ein Déjà-vu.
Also brauchen wir jetzt nicht einmal darüber reden,
dass es sinnlos ist, dass Swift abstürzt,
weil es in C++ und nicht in Swift geschrieben ist.
Zumindest der SecVault vielleicht.
Man kann auch ein unsicheres Swift schreiben.
Oh, bei mir ist, mir SecVaultet manchmal JavaScript beim Entwickeln.
Was?
Ich habe ja letzte Woche dann drüber gespielt,
unsere Node-Anwendungen zu packagen.
Und dieser Node-Packager,
Elektron-Packager,
ich weiß nicht, da muss ich mal reingucken.
Das Ding macht echt seltsames Zeugs.
Der macht fünf Minuten auf meinem
MacBook Volllast
auf Arbeit und zum Schluss kommt halt
so eine zweieinhalb Gigabyte Datei raus.
Das ist auch so, was du vorhin meintest.
Genau. Und ich weiß nicht,
ich habe mir noch eine nächste Zeit genommen.
Du kannst es ja, so eine.app-Datei
ist ja auf Mac auch bloß wieder ein Ordner, da kannst du dann reingehen,
hast du Resources und dann hast du da wieder
deine Node-Moduls verzeichnet. Wahrscheinlich,
ich habe, wie gesagt, nicht reingeguckt,
wahrscheinlich ist es so, dass dann da alles hundertmal drin liegt,
sonst kann ich mir nicht erklären, wie das so groß wird.
Dass der ab einer gewissen Stelle einfach aufhört.
Ich kann es nicht mehr so auf,
ich stamp jetzt alles dazwischen.
Ich habe auch schon mal eine Dependency hinzugefügt und es ist endlos gelaufen.
Oh Gott.
Aber was
mir manchmal passiert ist, dass ich an einer Stelle
diesen Packager anschmeiße, weil ich für
Kollegen unsere Elektron-App
packagen sollte. Und dann habe ich nebenbei weiterentwickelt
und dann habe ich Typescript ausgeführt und dann kriege
ich einen SecFont aus Node.js.
Und dann gucke ich rein
und dann sehe ich,
dass in meinem System diese maximalen
Zahl an offenen Dateien aufgenommen wird.
Und da fällt mir
jetzt BikeShed ein, die haben ja irgendwie so ähnliche
Probleme manchmal bei Rails 5
aus Gründen. Und das passiert
hier genauso. Das Ding geht über unsere
100 Megabyte
Typescript
wahrscheinlich alles auf und versucht, alle
Dependencies in Memory zu halten,
um dann irgendwann aus einem Schlag,
also der macht in deinem
Target-Verzeichnis, macht ja auch keine
Zwischendateien oder Temp-Dateien oder sowas,
der läuft,
fünf Minuten, sechs Minuten, acht Minuten
auf Volllast
und zack, zum Schluss ist er fertig und dann ist dein Ergebnis da.
Aber es ist einfach nur schlecht gebaut,
dann das Tool.
Ja.
Das ist doch, oh Gott.
So kann man es machen.
Du kannst nebenbei halt nicht weiterarbeiten, weil
halt nicht mal deinen Compiler ausführen kannst,
weil der dann segfoltet, weil dein System dann
irgendwie die Dateien ausgegangen
sind, die es auch machen kann.
Oh Mann. Schöne neue Welt.
Auf jeden Fall. Mit JavaScript bist du
so viel produktiver als mit C++.
Wir haben noch ein großes Thema für heute, das wir
eigentlich noch ansprechen wollten. Was ist denn so passiert
in den letzten Tagen? Da gab es doch
so einen schönen
Megafail weltweit.
Also du wieder mit deinen Umleitungen.
Ich heule gleich.
Es geht um WannaCry oder
WannaCrypt, je nachdem wie man es bezeichnet.
Ich habe beides gelesen oft. Ich bin mir gerade gar nicht mehr sicher,
wie das Ding eigentlich heißt, die Ransomware.
Ich erinnere mich, ich hatte
vor, ich glaube, zwei Wochen ist das
jetzt her, grob geschätzt.
Also je nachdem, ihr hört den Podcast,
das ist eh dann wieder egal, was für eine
Zeitspanne ich gerade sage. Heute ist übrigens
der 21. Mai.
Tag dieser Aufnahme.
Da ging
haben irgendwas los, dass das gesamte
britische Gesundheitssystem irgendwie
angegriffen wird
und die gerade alle im Arsch sind, weil die
alle Rechner oder Systeme
infiziert sind mit Randomware,
Ransomware, nicht Randomware, Ransomware,
die denn ihre Daten wegverschlüsselt hat
und Geld dafür haben möchte und Ärzte können
nicht mehr arbeiten und what the fuck.
Mir ist das oft gefallen, weil ich auf Twitter dann
Fotos von irgendwelchen Anzeigetafeln
auf Flughäfen und Bahnhöfen gekriegt habe.
Genau, dann ging es eben weiter und
dann war nebenher noch, glaube ich, Telefonica,
dieser Insight-Anbieter oder Handy-Netz-Betreiber war mit betroffen
und dann auch die Deutsche Bahn im Großen Züge.
Am nächsten Tag bin ich tatsächlich mit der Bahnhof hingefahren.
Am Dresdner Hauptbahnhof war alles down, alle Anzeigen waren aus.
Du hast auf manchen Anzeigen, ich habe es auf Twitter auch gesehen,
auf manchen Anzeigen am Dresdner Bahnhof Neustadt,
war der One-Equip-Ransomware-Dialog offen auf der Anzeige.
Genau, ich glaube, das eine Foto hatte sogar ein Kollege von mir selber gemacht in Dresden.
Das ist großartig.
Also das ist echt stark die Runde gemacht,
dieses Zeug.
Ransomware ist ja jetzt nichts Neues,
gibt es ja schon länger. Und gerade auch
Ransomware, die mit sauberer Verschlüsselung arbeitet
und deine Daten auch zurückgibt, wenn du
den Betrag planst. Es gab sogar schon Ransomware,
die in Rust geschrieben war.
Gibt es schon elektronbasierte Ransomware?
Ja, die legt dein System
für Stunden lahm.
Verbraucht deine Ressourcen.
Verbraucht deine Ressourcen und macht so viele Dateien
auf das alles andere kaputt.
Hey, du 300 Dollar hier zahlst,
diese Bitcoin-Adresse, dann löscht ich dieses Elektron-Ding
selber. Yes! Das ist mir wert.
Dann kriegst du die native Version.
Nee, aber das Spannende,
wie sich das ja verbreitet hat, ist,
anfangs haben Leute spekuliert, wie es das tut und
in den Anhängen, das soll uns wohl nicht gewesen sein.
Und dann kam eben raus,
dass das über eine Vulnerability ging,
die über die Shadow Brokers mit veröffentlicht wurde,
also über diesen Leak vom
CIA-Krams. Und die haben
da eben eine Samba-Vulnerability mit
drinstehen gehabt. Deswegen dieser Comic Stop Use
Samba V1.
Es gibt so ein Memen,
da kommt ein Alien-Raumschiff
auf die Erde und die Menschen verstehen
seine Sprache nicht und das ist halt so ein Alien,
das guckt aus dem UFO raus
und unten siehst du aber bloß Cavemen,
das sind alles bloß so Steinzeitmenschen
und der sagt dann
Stop using irgendwas
Samba V1 Version 1
und die Menschen so
Verstehst du wovon er redet?
Nein, und dann zeigen sie dir Finger hoch
und das A zeigt so die Finger zurück
und fliegt weg.
Nett, nett.
Ja, aber diese Vulnerability wurde halt von Microsoft
auch zeitnah gepatcht, das ist sogar schon
eine Zeit lang jetzt wieder her, aber niemand hat
halt Updates installiert.
Microsoft hat es jetzt sogar rückwirkend noch für
Windows XP gepatcht, obwohl das
ja wirklich für XP...
Das ist die erste Sicherheitslücke,
oder die einzige Sicherheitslücke, die sie für XP
in den letzten Jahren... Also es ist ja XP nur noch für alles
andere außer dem...
Das trifft halt richtig fucking viele Systeme.
Und das hat sich verbreitet wie Wildfeuer.
Ich habe gehört, es war auf unserer
Kaffeemaschine.
Das haben wir vor ein paar Tagen
nochmal kurz am Donnerstag geshoppt gehabt.
Ich finde es schön, dass es
einer unserer populären Tweets in letzter Zeit
gewesen ist.
Zumindest eine Person hat es auch
geglaubt.
Das fand ich sehr witzig.
Ich tue mal den Link dazu in die Show Notes.
Aber es ist ja gar nicht mal so
unwahrscheinlich. Das ist ja wirklich auf
vielem gelaufen. Das lief auf Bankautomaten, hast du
diesen Pop-Up gesehen oder
diese GUI.
Das ist echt beeindruckend gewesen.
Ja, da siehst du doch mal wieder,
dass du als Staat
oder als CIA oder
als FBI oder als
irgendwer solche Sicherheitslücken nicht
einkaufen und horten sollst, damit du die
irgendwann mal gegen deine Feinde einsetzen kannst,
sondern dass du bitte einfach als
Land, als
sollst, um Infrastruktur sicher zu machen.
Oh ja.
Es gibt ja viele Leute
auch vom Cars Computer Club, die sagen,
der deutsche Staat sollte
Sicherheitslücken einkaufen und
dann veröffentlichen, damit
dieser Markt ausgetrocknet wird
und damit die Leute nicht
unendlich viel Geld dafür verlangen.
Steigert das nicht nur die Nachfrage?
Dann ist es teurer.
Ja, das ist natürlich
Investition und Sicherheit.
Das ist jetzt Geld, was du ausgibst,
damit nichts passiert.
Aber jetzt ist halt was passiert und woran lag es?
Das FBI hat halt Sicherheitslücken gehortet.
CIA hat Sicherheitslücken gehortet.
Irgendwann sind sie geleakt worden und
dann sehen halt Leute, oh Zero Days, guck mal.
Probieren wir gleich mal was aus.
Also es ging echt zügig.
Das ist noch nicht so lange her, der Leak.
Das hat sich
ultraschnell verbreitet, dadurch, dass es halt eben keinen
menschlichen Kontakt brauchte, um da irgendwelche
E-Mail-Anhänge sich einzuschleusen,
sondern hat halt direkt einfach automatisiert
Wunderabilities ausgenutzt. Witzig fand ich
das Detail, dass das so schnell es da war,
auch wieder gestoppt wurde, durch eine
witzige Methodik, nämlich hat ein Sicherheitsforscher
gesehen, dass das Ding
einen Web-Request an eine ganz bestimmte Domain
absetzt, nachdem es auf einem System
infiziert hat. Und er hat die Domain einfach
mal registriert, um
da eben dann weiter mit rumzuspielen.
Die waren auch absichtlich nicht registriert,
denn
was viel
Trojaner und Ransomware und alles
andere macht, die wollen
wissen, ob sie an der VM ausgeführt werden, damit
die eben, gerade wenn sie eben
von Sicherheitsvorschern eben ausgeführt werden,
nicht preisgeben, was sie so tun,
sondern nur auf echten
Systemen tatsächlich die Systeme befallen können.
Der VW-Effekt sozusagen.
Achso, genau.
Du siehst, ob du auf dem Triffstand läufst oder nicht.
Genau das.
Und was da in gängiger Praxis ist,
das zu tun, ist einfach mal
einen Random Request ins Internet absetzen, an der
Domain, die nicht existiert, die nicht registriert ist,
und zu schauen, dass die nicht auflöst.
Denn was viele VMs machen, ist, die routen einfach alle Requests auf den Localhost zurück,
aber halt auch für nicht existierende Domains.
Und da kannst du einfach mal bekannte Trojaner machen,
die machen einfach fünf Requests an randomstrings.com
und wenn die alle fünf zurückkommen und sagen, löst nicht auf,
dann sind sie auf einem System, was gerade keine VM ist, wahrscheinlich.
Ah, weil sie ans echte Internet rankommen.
Genau. Und WannaCry oder WannaCrypt, über das Ding das heißt,
er hat halt an eine hartgecodete Domain diesen Request geschickt.
Irgendwann, der Typ, der registriert hat,
haben alle WannaCry-Instanzen gedacht zu laufen auf VMS.
In dem Moment war WannaCry gestoppt.
Es hat sich zumindest nicht neu ausgebreitet.
Hat halt gedacht, es läuft überall auf der VMS und war erst mal...
Ja, gib doch mal bitte jemand dem Typen ein Bier aus.
Haben auch viele Leute gemacht.
Aber finde ich interessant.
Die Taktik kannte ich vorher nicht.
Die habe ich auch erst dadurch mit erfahren, wie man das so macht.
Und ich finde es halt schon ein Oversight von dem Typen,
der die Sowjetunion geschrieben hat,
dass das halt nur die eine Harpy Call-Domain nimmt.
random string so lang. Ja, das ist so
XKCD-Randomness, du hast beim
Programmieren nur 4 gewürfelt und dann schreibst du halt
4 da rein.
Get random number, return 4, chosen by
5 dice roll.
Ja, hätte es halt ein bisschen mehr
genommen als nur eine und dann wäre das nicht so
einfach gewesen, aber es ging auch später
wieder weiter mit
ähnliche Trojaner und
Schadsoftware, die halt dieselbe
Renewability ausgenutzt haben, aber halt nicht
diesen einen Oversight mit drin hatten, aber die hat sich
nicht mehr so verbreitet, weil die Leute tatsächlich überall
bis sie was abdesinstalliert haben.
Vieles zumindest,
nicht alle.
Oh Mann.
Aber das war schon sehr, sehr spannend, muss ich
sagen, wie schnell sich das vor allem
verbreitet hat. Und ich fand es sehr wichtig, dass
die Deutsche Bahn in diesem Ausmaß
so toll war.
Haben sich schon alle Institutionen wieder
davon erholt? Keine Ahnung.
Es gibt auch Gerüchte, dass der
Bitcoin-Preis deswegen auch mit in die Höhe schießt,
weil Institutionen jetzt Bitcoin horten,
um sowas in Zukunft zu zeigen.
Ich habe mal geguckt, ob ich mir mal wieder welche hole.
Wir sind gerade bei über 2000 Dollar
angekommen. Alter, wenn ich einfach
vor drei Jahren mal eine gekauft hätte.
Ach, wäre das schön. Da könnte man mal schön
in den Urlaub fahren.
Ist eigentlich bei Flatter was passiert?
Sehr witzig. Wir hatten ja über Flatter gesprochen.
Und die haben jetzt irgendwie eine Mail
rumgeschickt, dass sie Flatter
neu launchen wollen.
Ich habe nämlich nochmal geguckt. Ich hatte ja in der letzten Folge
gesagt, dass für Naubi
nur exakt einer mal geflattert hat.
Und dann habe ich geguckt
und da stand plötzlich wieder Null.
Das ist kaputt, ist mein Account ausgelaufen?
Und irgendwie
bauen die gerade um. Ich fand es witzig,
weil wir gerade zufällig über die gesprochen haben und ich habe
seit Jahren nicht mehr vom Flatter gehört.
Und direkt nachdem wir darüber reden,
übrigens neues Flatter.
Ich weiß auch nicht, was die Unterschiede sind,
was sie anders machen wollen.
Aber spaßig, die leben noch
und wollen Dinge. Sind da jetzt meine 37
Cent weg oder was?
Das wäre traurig.
Ja, gar nicht.
Es wäre schon schön, wenn du es schaffen würdest,
diese Minimalbeträge
direkt ausgezahlt zu bekommen.
Lohnt sich das?
Ich meine, du hast überall Transaktionsgebühren.
Ich bestehe nicht drauf, dass...
Lohnt es sich,
sich 37 Cent über Bitcoin auszahlen zu lassen?
Bitcoin erst recht nicht. Wir haben gerade Transaktionsgebühren
bei Bitcoin, die gehen in Euronähe.
Ich habe gestern für Transaktion 1,50
gezahlt. Du benutzt noch Bitcoin?
Ich benutze Bitcoin, ja.
genau einmal im Monat.
Auch ein bisschen öfter für Kleinscheiß.
Wir hatten ja letzte Woche Vorstandsversammlung
beim ASCII im Studentencafé.
Da ist die Bitcoin-Gruppe aufgerufen worden.
Die Bitcoin-Gruppe im Verein
bist du.
Das ist korrekt.
Ich glaube, man wird nie wieder im ASCII mit Bitcoin zahlen können, oder?
Du kannst im ASCII zahlen, wenn du halt aktuell
die Transaktionsgebühren, die eine komplette
Extramate beinhalten,
mittragen möchtest.
Nee, oder? Damit das Bitcoin eigentlich gestorben wird.
das muss Bitcoin mal wieder in den Griff kriegen.
Das geht halt gerade alles ein bisschen aus dem Ruder.
Aber es geht ja so oft, irgendwas
aus dem Ruder bei Bitcoin, das ist ja ganz normal.
Aber der Kurs
ist echt beeindruckend gerade.
Ja, ich habe es mir mal kurz angeguckt und habe gleich gedacht,
oh Gott, oh Gott, eigentlich müsste ich diese
anderthalb Euro, die mittlerweile
bestimmt fünf Euro sind, die ich hatte,
mal abstoßen. Möchtest du ein paar Bitcoin
von mir haben? Nee, passt schon,
danke.
Ja, das ist immer schlimm. Also wenn ich
meine Bitcoin-App
Handy aktualisiere, dann sagt die mir übrigens,
übrigens, du hast ja noch Geld drauf.
Nur, dass du es weißt, nicht vergessen.
Könnt ihr nochmal
GitHub-Star aufzählen? Ich habe mir noch eine
Sache gefunden gehabt,
war auch auf Hacker News vor ein paar Tagen.
Hast du das Genetic Hello World gesehen?
Das ist ein schönes Beispiel
für genetische Algorithmen.
Das sind 150 Zahlen JavaScript
und wenn du es aufmachst, drückst du auf
Start und da steht da
Rauschen und irgendwie die Zahl, die hin
immer kleiner wird,
ist der Abstand
zum Endergebnis. Das ist jetzt gerade
9000, 8000, 7000, 6000, das ist ziemlich
schnell. Du bist bei 500 Generationen
mit 3000, 2000, 1000
und irgendwann zum Schluss
flab, flab, flab, flab, flab, 30, 10,
5, steht da, Hello World
nach 871
Generationen bei dir. Ich habe es auch schon mal
in 700 geschafft und mal in
1200, das ist immer ein bisschen zufällig.
Okay, was genau,
wie läuft das, was macht der?
der modifiziert quasi
der fängt mit Zufall an
und modifiziert das immer ganz ganz wenig
und versucht wie weit
du siehst jetzt hier, dass es sich immer wieder Stück für Stück
nur ganz ganz wenig verändert
und so zufällige Modifikationen hast bis zum Schluss
nach immer im Schnitt so um die
1000 Generationen dann bei Hello World angekommen.
Und du versuchst in der Gruppe in die richtige Richtung zu schubsen
indem du den Abstand berechnest und dem sagst
es muss kleiner werden. Genau, das ist so eine Kostenfunktion
die dann läuft. Okay, witzig.
Das ist eigentlich geil.
Das Schöne ist, dass es in JavaScript geschrieben ist
und 150 Zeilen lang ist. Das heißt, das kannst
du mal eben an 150 Zeilen inklusive
dem HTML drumherum
und da Printing.
Das ist eigentlich ganz schön.
Wollen wir uns dann dabei belassen für heute?
Können wir machen.
Da haben wir mal eine etwas kürzere Folge gemacht.
Also, vielen Dank
für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Das war
akronomisierbar Folge 6.
Immer noch 6. Stimmt. Ja, ich dachte,
wir sind bei der 7.
7 nehmen wir dann nächsten Monat auf.
Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören, ihr seid toll
Schreibt uns Feedback auf Twitter
Genau, vielen Dank
und der nächste Podcast in eurem Player
kommt in 3, 2, 1